so
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
can you hear me
does everything get in your body
[Music]
i said
so
nobody
[Music]
i don't think
i don't feel better but i gotta work
tonight the good thing about tonight
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack do all
that good stuff that we need to do and
um
you know we're about to get started i am
well it's not important who i am
uh what's important is that you are
pulling up to the iron lords podcast
right now as we speak and uh i guess i'm
here to keep you entertained until it's
time to get this show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on the song with
me that's understandable i kill a beat
and they want to compare me to freddie
and jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game
just be original y'all so dramatical i
know it's random but i'm addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
[Music]
you could say that i'm very spoiled for
them to be your dog thing very loyal but
i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here to
boy you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell an uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
but that's all a part of me being
accountable and they say i'm better than
money because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they wanna compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game
just be original y'all so dramatical i
know it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is the yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start
regardless back we were messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
[Music]
to say it i'm embarrassed for you i
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lord's
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but coming to find out that they're
really mechanical
and yeah i'll be eating these rappers
but that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game
just be original y'all so dramatical i
know it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
um
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they're
really mechanical
and yeah i'll be eating these rappers
but that's all a part of me being a
cannibal
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i'm addicted to flipping
when i'm in the range i was the hardest
to start regardless back we was
messaging people on
[Music]
i'm very spoiled for them to be your dog
thing very loyal but i ain't gonna hold
you i ain't here to boy you you ain't
gotta say it i'm embarrassed for you i
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they're really
mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i am addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
for you i've always been a nerd never
been a loser making voltron with a gang
of cougars and i'm going places better
tell her uber cause it's pretty hard to
sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
um
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tiller uber
cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being a cannibal
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i am addicted to flipping the
sample and making
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on
aim
[Music]
for them to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i've always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lord's
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all mess up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they wanna compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i am addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable this is
that
this is the yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back
with messaging people check my vocals
all
on twitter but i'm anti-social love my
city but i'm still by coastal
[Music]
i've always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i'm addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people on aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
very loyal
a proclamation
[Music]
if i can imagine this cooler give you
some advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cause if you don't give her
that
option you're gonna be single player
like siren you're gonna get tossed in
the bushes by king david
royalty ain't not a pretender
detrimental to an elemental what's an
avatar
that's cool but i got bad news even if
you really was that you can't never
still be the king of the statues
since the juvenile i've been cursed with
a curse to be musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in the crucible was it in
nothing it's cool and it's beautiful we
let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a sunday
it's suitable cause you can listen to
this in your cubicle
on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
[Music]
all right i found it i wanted a
welcome to episode 198 of the iron lord
podcast what's up everybody i am your
standing host today lord sovereign
uh standing up for the boss lord cognito
if you guys have been following him on
twitter you know that uh he's had
uh some surgery this week and he's in
recovery and he's
of course left the animals to run wild
this week
and you guys uh are other privileged
ones to have to deal with that so uh
again welcome to episode 198 i cannot
believe we're two episodes away from
200. it's craziness
yo this is bonkers right it just goes by
like nothing it's been like three years
like where is it going
craziness oh man so
let me welcome to the realm this week
return it we have two guests the other
guest is in the bushes right now who'll
be here
in a minute but we have a i like to call
the free agent extraordinaire
lady cuts for the win returning to the
realm
lady erica thank you for coming back
it's been a minute what have you been up
to just
it's been what maybe over a year or
something yeah it's been a minute um
free agent for what was that free agent
exploding there
extraordinaire you're out there doing
your thing yeah i like that
thank you guys for having me it's it's
awesome to be back um i can't wait to
just talk games with you guys and yeah
you know i'm showing a little left for
sony today you know try to give them
some support
they need it do they need support
yeah they might they might they haven't
you know
[Music]
we never know what that guess sometimes
you know he could be on the other side
of
history i think he's on the right side
of the wrong with me
yeah i know i know these are going to be
some interesting interactions today this
is just
listen let's get to super chat no doubt
we got actually two phone calls
yeah i have that one have that we have
titan 2793 with the five dollar super
chat royalty piece of cognito use your
intro style on zoom
i was the man keep them coming so
incognito yes cognito is uh
always imitated so uh fantastic that you
were able to get some love from that
um and i will pass that along to the
boss then we have
the living flame five dollar super chat
hear ye
hear ye oh no jim clown shoes ryan has
declared
that the xbox ecosystem is the best
place to play
i hope everyone kept those games to pc
energy
i told you your man was compliant from
the day i saw him
i knew where he was at
the puppet do you know what's funny
i uh i was watching a podcast the other
day i can't remember what it was and
if that singer was in there dead singer
called him jim dance with bro
uh man i already forgot his name yeah
jim there you go
listen and what's funny is like everyone
in there i guess that's the first time
they've ever heard it
they just they they they couldn't stop
laughing like
yeah i i've read a couple of articles
right and it's funny because
even like like regular journalists say
things
in in the vein of dancing around things
like they've been like oh wow
like jim ryan was dancing around this
this topic or whatever i'm like oh my
god
that's what's right again i'm telling
you man if you don't know my
oh you were in the classroom i wanted
you to hear the song that i bopped into
man and i knew you would love this song
too but i was like i was holding a hope
for hope man
yo i'ma let you hear it at the end but
yo it's a serious bop tuning ah
no doubt definitely popping right now
let me get these super chats and i
introduce blaze we got michael aka best
size finance with the ten dollars to
protect good morning lords
i'm just enjoying vacation with my wife
in vegas but we're heading back to san
diego so
so we're listening to the iron lords as
we head back four and a half
hour drive lords and xbox gang 100
yeah i don't know we're gonna give you a
four and a half hour show today
but we're gonna get you halfway home we
might get you halfway there yeah
definitely
a couple of uh a couple of restaurants
bro yeah
we can't be doing that four-hour stuff i
got i gotta cut listen i got a couple of
scoldings last week
good lord not a good situation here
then we have a smitty smith with 2000
jack salute lords lord cognito heal up
brother yes sir look
you know cog this is this is where all
your patreon money goes to i hope you
know you okay
you know you guys donate to us and take
care of us and cox so he needed a little
work done so he was like you know
i'm gonna stop that right now yo in a
couple of weeks i'm gonna show you how
my life was like [ __ ]
because you got a hoofy dude keep it
coming
someone's gonna someone's gonna clip
that they're gonna be like see look
what's going on
damn lord botox
troubleshooters in the building also gym
dance moves ryan aka
jimmy john man right oh my gosh
yeah you're about to be on fire let this
man out his name right here we got
somebody's
beginning today lord king on this day we
ride out on these fools hashtag bayonets
up and
book of x is enhanced salute we
understand what today means
oh my lord we acknowledge time of day
erica you still have time to change your
shirt if you want i mean
oh man
that we have the medic with the five
dollar super chat
eating brunch while it's in the iop is a
perfect start to a lazy sunday also got
my ilp
swagging early this week fantastic
beautiful sir thank you thank you 40 sir
appreciate it
all right and of course we have our
second guest returning to the realm
playstation nation's own rgt podcast
member
co-host of the solid cast with the
brother lord solid rev
and boston's finest place 4k what's up
brother you gotta
can you hold up we gotta say king you
gotta do it what you gotta do it
do what don't
when i was watching that reaction man i
i
when that happened it's when i
officially lost it i lost all
hope for king when he did that
what's going on man everything's good
man how are you guys doing what happened
with cod
cog is [ __ ] has surgery during the week
so he
is in the bushes surgery yeah surgery is
a major surgery
you know if you have to but you know he
was a walk or whatever just very minor
stuff
uh so you guys don't have to worry too
much you know um you know everything was
sterile he wasn't exposed to cold yet
you know
everything yeah um he's recovering very
well you know we just had to tell him
that he can't show up today he has to
sit down yeah he has to relax and
he does a hell of a lot so he needed his
time off sit down and relax
exactly executive decisions were made
and and that was that but i hope he's
not listening though because if he
starts laughing it's not going to be a
good situation
so he we might bust your stitches so hey
bro
i'll bust your stitches
he's definitely listening because i'm on
the iop account and
he just he just tied so he's definitely
listening because that wasn't me
so he he's here yeah he's here
don't laugh so blaze man
what have you been up to brother what's
going on bro i've been uh
i've been holding the line bro
has it been a tough week sir it's been a
very hard week
look you know i've been good it's just
uh
you know everybody thinks you know we're
gonna get into it but yeah
jim ryan's a fraud bro yeah just just
just hold him
see like like like i tell you the reason
why
i love this man yeah because he
he's not gonna fraud he's not gonna
fraud for nobody you know you got a lot
of dudes that's on that side of the camp
that'll sit in front of the camera and
be like yo x y and z and try to act like
it's one way
but he's gonna tell the truth and i
really respect that because it's a lot
of dudes and your camp they like to clip
my clips and like to hold my name
and to like run around with my name in
their mouth and they don't
really give it up so you really do and
you really a gamer because
actually you know i had a playstation uh
pro when
you was repping playstation and some
dudes wasn't just you know a lot of
shots i want them to clip that clip that
part
just uh just uh uh we need the mods to
jump in here and
get whoever is on the iron lord's
podcast account writing fraudery in the
chat saab is not fired i don't know who
that is
writing style inspired in the chat um
and a big shout out to blizzard's oh
mike ibarra in the chat
thank you my brother has been a minute
since we've heard from you in our chat
so thank you for coming through
um so i forgot to ask erica and of
course blaze uh what have you guys been
playing what
what's been on the docket as a blade oh
man um well i beat
little nightmares too last night which
was awesome it's a nice game
it's a mind trip i played the first one
and so i was looking forward to the
second one
really creepy moments um the atmosphere
i mean what they did with that game i
felt like they they kind of uh
went beyond the first game as far as
like creativity and
and and it's crazy when you play it like
you'll notice like the depth of
view or yeah depth of field they do
things with it where
like the background will be blurry or
the foreground and and there's something
about that that like makes it creepier
the way they do it so i i i noticed that
they they really went all out it was a
good game
um i played that beat that and then i
played the outriders demo i don't know
if you guys did
yeah yeah i was pleasantly surprised i i
guess i didn't really have expectations
going in or something i just didn't
really know what to think
um but it was actually a good time you
have to forgive air because she doesn't
know any better
no no no wait a minute okay so
okay so for me the big thing with
outriders is how much of the loop
feels like a lunar shooter even though
they say it's not
she's uh she's she's the target audience
i might be right right target audience
because
um they want fresh eyes like she said
she had no expectations for it
you know and she's pleasantly surprised
so
with that being said you're the person
that they're targeting
you know they're not targeting me or
they're not targeting somebody that's a
division head
uh they understand why loyalties lie
they're targeting
[Music]
you'll definitely be on to it so yeah
absolutely this is something i should
try then
and then this is something yes yes i'll
yeah cause i've played division two i
like it with friends
it's a good time it's cool but like you
said like the loyalty type thing like
where i'm on it grinding all the time i
don't do that yeah so
yeah god yeah that ain't me that ain't
me so
outriders it was cool it was kind of
funny kind of cheesy story and things
like that but it's kind of like
it had me laughing so i was like i took
it as a good thing it was a good time
and then yeah and then besides that just
been kind of the occasional gears i'm
always on gears
so um that's my kind of go-to
multiplayer but yeah
were you disappointed with that tease
that turned out not to be gears 2
remake yeah remastered you know we
expected it we did not
expect no gears to remake i mean we we
saw the picture and had the same you
know they're holding the cog tags kind
of the same way that
gears 2 um cover art did but in the back
of my head i'm like don't erica don't
believe it don't because they trust them
don't trust it because they constantly
um disappoint so sure enough
it's just the operation six which is the
multiplayer
like the new season yeah so what about
you blaze what you
what you've been blazing my man what you
what you been blazing brother
i've been playing role company that's
just my multiplayer game uh yeah sir i
know
i've been playing mini golf on on the
computer with everybody like i know it
sounds stupid but golf
on the computer like mini golf mad fun
uh golf is fun to play
what was that power shots that i was
playing on my vita
hot shots
[Applause]
boy you couldn't tell me anything that
that was my joint
i bought 2k uh you know i didn't know 2k
makes golf now like you know like the
tiger took over the uh the pga likes
yeah yeah that shit's fire too but um
right it's dry
[Laughter]
but it's dry it's very dry man it's
perfect
there's nothing to play man no matter
what console you got there's zero games
nah that's not true but
i mean you already know i'm gonna tell
you that's not true but
no king what are you playing okay well
i'm gonna get to that
when he calls me up i'll get to that
it's actually every week
i literally leave out like 10 games off
my list
be honest with you you know that i've
been actually playing touching
and you know enjoying yo looking plays
his face
i'm not gonna lie when when sovereign
you know gives me my intro then uh
all right and of course we have the lord
of the realm minus the boss
in the building we have the young wolf
the co-host of the iop
lord addict who i believe is in the bush
so you're not going to be talking very
much today but lord addict are you there
sir
yes i am here what's going on brother i
know you don't feel great
a little under the weather uh you know
pretty much the only thing i've been
playing
for like the past three weeks is dragon
quest 11.
yes uh i finally beat it after three
weeks of playing that game religiously
like this man what's crazy is like
he calls me last night he goes oh i beat
it
i said yo i am such a fraud yo
i said i just made it into the city
after coming down off the mountain
i was like i was like what was your play
time 100 hours
it was like it was like 80 something
almost 90. but
it was just like i felt like that game
was never ending
like i think that's a lot of people's
take on it like it's like it just keeps
going and going and going
it's just one of those games that like
and then they have like a
pre ending that's not the actual ending
right it's so nice so you have a lot of
people that's like oh if you don't beat
both the bosses you didn't really beat
dragon quest which
at first i didn't understand that
concept but when i played it i'm like
okay they're kind of right
like yeah yeah that game is and this is
the full sort of this is everything this
is the full package right the one that's
in gamepad right yeah
yes sir they don't they don't skimp out
in game pass yeah
it's not like you know they give you a
portion of the game and then you know
you get a timer like ea access you have
played you're taking
hours of gameplay now you must pay no
no yeah i'll tell you like i i'm i'm
frauding on jrpgs man it's such a time
sync i'm like when can i
even begin to think about starting a
jrpg and really like
i stopped playing ff7 and now that that
upgrade is coming i'm like all right
i'll just i'll continue now
but i haven't started i never started oh
that's right it hasn't come out for you
okay that's right
it won't come out for me until the next
consoles you know um and then
that's a whole fact you know especially
for what they said
all right so since this isn't a topic
we'll talk about it quickly what do you
feel about the
the yuffie the yuffie uh little episode
king addict what do you feel about the
yuppie episode being
exclusive to playstation i i don't know
how i feel about these little episodes
playstation buying you know i don't know
maybe seven hours of content maybe i
don't know like
it just feels petty i don't like it i
don't like okay
first first of all if microsoft did
something like that they would have been
picking it in the street
um this is something we expect from sony
they do uh
little uh spiteful things like this and
they force you to uh you know
buy into the ecosystem where i believe
that philosophy
is dead we're gonna get to the topic
yeah i i when i saw
it i said well i wasn't buying it for
you guys anyway i'm gonna force them to
release their content on uh
another you know console which they
probably might do when they become a
publisher so
it is what it is wow you know listen man
i i don't even scoff when king says
things anymore man this
too much has come to pass bro and i'm
the one that always scoffs and he what
he said
everything i said is true so with that
let's transition to the incredible hug
of the ilp
the king of the statues the beloved lord
king what's going on brother
oh man i mean first of all i'm gonna do
this ooh ooh
um second of all i'm gonna hit you with
the tina
[Music]
that's fantastic that is 1500 of xm
studios beautiful green goblin
i'm gonna thank everybody that showed up
yesterday for that live unboxing
smitty smith is the realest dude um you
see him super chat here
he's super chat's over there and it's
not even about the super chat it's just
about the man supports me
in a great manner and a lot of people do
you know not even if you you super chat
it's not even about that it's about you
coming through and showing some support
and you know these high-end collectibles
not everybody because uh you know dude
on twitter was like yo king you should
put up these pictures
first of all whenever i put up a picture
that's for
promo for you to go watch the show all
right
i'm not sitting there and i'm not doing
the uh cleaning up the pictures and all
that other stuff i don't i'm just giving
you a peek
into my life and for the collectors who
actually collect
they know what the statue looks like
they when they watch it they say okay
let me put the order in let me get the
statue if i can because it's a low
edition size there's only 238 of them
made
very low so uh fantastic statue
uh second i want to say uh to everborn
um my man my brother the guest that was
on the show last week
please everyone again go to
everbornsaga.com
and uh order some swag order the books
um i got this stuff so fast
these books so fast uh he personalized
the stuff to me
fantastic shipping great story uh
great fantastic stuff uh you see the
game
because uh we didn't get a chance to
show the game uh
last week so you get a chance to see the
game it's it's a fantastic
run for a young entrepreneur realizing
his dream
and he's our comrade he's making games
he's
making what we dream to do i know
everybody sits around
and we complain about certain games what
we would do
while he's actually taking that same
energy and putting it forth and getting
it done
um i saw canelo
versus his sparring partner yesterday
and um and literally that's his sparring
partner that's that's it
he made sure his man got the bag too
what y'all guys got a chance to watch
was when you saw um
floyd floyd did this before too with
andre birdo and that was his last you
know official uh
fight when he fought andre berto and
they made up this fake uh thing that
andre berto was having
you know uh relations with one of his
ex-girlfriends or his girlfriend
and and trying to make it a thing and
they built the fight up and it was
millions of dollars on the line and
people was complaining
saying that can't be your last fight
with this that in the third uh this guy
you know he does he's not a match andre
berto is a real fighter this dude last
night was not
i mean anybody puts on the gloves that
goes in the ring you risk your life
right i'm saying that but this guy
was literally there just for the bag he
got couple of million dollars
uh to fight his literal sparring partner
he got hit with a couple of shots
knocked down and just didn't come out i
know blaze i know you saw it i know
you you saw us off uh i saw bits and
pieces of it i had it on on the computer
i didn't have
any sound on um but it just looked like
a thrashing like
but again like seeing how he was kind of
keeping that distance
and not engaging and then when he
finally did hit him with something it
was just
again i let's just say that i'm glad i
did not uh
i i didn't pay full price for that he
was going to the body a lot man
he was you know man but
man i mean i guess i don't know if this
is the results of cobit or whatever
but it's just we need to get we need to
start making some better fights
well as you notice i haven't been doing
my combat talk with the kids yeah
um because of colvit and how covet has
affected
my uh my passion my my my chosen sport
to love um
yeah so this is a result of certain
things like that but hopefully he gets a
chance to fight uh
jamal charlo and um he can actually step
up to the fight
uh i think he would try to take the
arrow spence route
right and if he ever does
that either one of those two is a super
dangerous fight i think he has a better
chance at beating
spence opposed to beating charlo i think
charlo uh
beats the brakes off of him charlotte's
he's just physically
stronger like spencer's a technician for
sure
yeah and he's a slower footer fighter
right i think
uh you know canelo has more fleet of
foot and will have
more hand speed going into it so i think
he poses a bigger threat towards ariel
spence
all right so what i've been playing guys
oh man so
blaze asked me what i was playing so we
all know destiny so we know
destiny is my college job um that i
grind and i'm taking midterms every week
and every week is a final test and
you know doing different things with
destiny so and my uh
console choice come on brothers anyway
so um i played outright as demo oh
king you don't never play demos this is
true
this is true um i played little monsters
uh i will go through my list i play
uh the baleen uh
what's that the bladeling company game
that that demo what is that the ballin
bowling company oh ballin
uh uh ballin underworld yeah yeah bottom
wonder world
yo super lucky's tale uh i'm i'm a
junkie for that
and um sniper elite
uh all the games that was in uh the
boost mode
i told you about that boost mode oh i
went back yeah you said super lucky
still
yes sir well there's nothing wrong with
that
good game i'm great i was about to say
i'm about to say i was playing that 120
frames per second free
yeah 120 frames per second free
but okay so let's get to this outriders
demo that i
touch okay game is not for me okay
because really it's absolutely not
because it tries to be
everything and i noticed when erica said
she was pleasantly surprised she's a
gears head
i am automatically from the rip before
the powers kick
in it feels like a uh a rip off of gears
uh a little a couple things but go ahead
right a couple
a couple of things they just give you a
familiarity to the game
like when you slide behind cover the
going behind cover and coming out from
behind cover is so smooth
the running is is open the world looks
very nice
and then i felt a bit of division it
felt like definition as well
it feels like it's super fast compared
to like a gears
or even a division like it almost felt
like just watching it
it felt like it took that and it almost
felt like you remember um
vanquished like the way vanquish moves
from cover to cover like that fast and
like yeah
yeah he's sliding into the next cover
yeah so
that's what it feels like i i want to
check the field of view you can't open
it wider to 104 or 105.
so it's exactly wherever it's at it's
probably somewhere around 80 or 90.
and um the world is realized in a good
manner it looks like a playstation 3
game
um at 60 frames per second why not a 360
game why are you going to say
no i got to be playing three right yeah
well it don't
the reason why i say a playstation 3
game because i thought playstation 3
had real sharp graphics right
and i thought uh playstation 3 like
because i'm thinking about dragging dog
bone
right yeah yeah yeah so i'm looking at
the characters uh
how they're made up with the polygons
with the hair and stuff like that
how do you play that king dragon dogma
no no where'd you play uh
um the demo oh on series x okay i played
it on pc that's why i was asking oh okay
okay yeah so
um it look it looks it felt that's what
the models the character models look
like that and felt like that to me
right right and um though but the world
looks very nice the frame rate is really
good
uh in certain cut scenes it drops a
little bit
but when i got to the powers i said okay
now i'm getting to the meat and the
grind of the game
where they put you in this little
battlefield that i felt kind of cheesy
like she said it felt really cheesy
and i'm fighting these guys and i took
my powers i took the firepower
and i'm like okay i'm throwing the fire
and i'm doing this and i'm doing that
and i'm like this is what division
needed so this might being that
division is stagnant this will pull
all of the division crowd in
and i i believe this is this because i
couldn't find a space for it i was like
i don't know what space it would take i
think this is going to steal
every last division players attention
and give new hope to a beginning and
this might be that
solid number two that we need to
when destiny have his oil time or it
might be your solid number one to take
over for division
so if you're a division head and you
really like division and you just didn't
like the spongy nature of some of the
enemies
this might be your outlet and this might
be
it for you i'm going to give it another
one i'm going to check it out a little
bit more
and i'm going to see the other uh uh um
subclasses
but i think this pulls
from division's uh fan base and this
might be it right here
king you should try the trickster the uh
do with the blue ability
like the one that's like a hunter for
the uh yeah
bro it was so much better bro and by the
way
not to disrespect gears because i love
games right but
it felt like these are the guys that
made bullet storm by the way
and and they worked on gear and they
worked on this game
yeah they did judgment um but it felt
like a
if gears evolved in terms of in terms of
the
faster movement and stuff like that it
was okay bro like i like the blood i
like
right it looked like you're right though
it did look like if you hit the
inventory it looked like destiny
right the cover looked like the vision
and the ears
it they look like they're grabbing from
every game yes sir yes
so it didn't look that bad bro
yeah i i have reverence for the
playstation 3.
i have huge reverence for the
playstation 3. i don't
see that's like a blight in a sony
fan base uh head that's not a blight in
my head i paid
700 for the console i stood outside for
the console
i rode for the first uh one when they
released it
i i don't i don't care about that i
really thought it was it was very good
high points in the playstation 3.
don't don't don't take when i say the
playstation 3 models
i thought playstation 3 had a sharpness
to it
um uh with certain games and then when
you
got into the games you saw certain
character models
i'm just talking about the character
models i know they went a certain route
with it to keep that speed and that
frame rate up
and when you have you know your three
people in your party and you have the
people in the world
i saw things that made me my eyebrow go
up and say
dag this will knock out division off of
my
my desktop this is this is going to come
off of this
because usually i keep it in my home
screen division 2
and i haven't been right this might take
that
out this is the thing that's crazy
interesting
yeah it's very interesting because to me
like again everything that i heard
like if you just look at this game from
the outside you immediately think it's
in that vein right it's that that
destiny it's that division two and then
when he started talking about no it's
not that
i'm like wait a minute okay so what is
the loop
how how are people like if you're saying
this is could be a replacement for
people who are division fans
where is that loop then where is that
like you you get the clothing and you
get the
uh you get the stuff but it's just a
finite thing it's not like a forever
thing
yeah but at the same time it has a
beginning and it has an end
from what they're saying but then they
saying they have
extra spots that takes it beyond
so that beyond content is where we're
going to see it live or die
okay you know what when the game like
this comes by
um bro i wasn't even thinking about all
right so right the fact that
i downloaded play it and it was actually
enjoyable i'm like oh like when the
game's not on my radar and i actually
like it
yeah it's a good thing yeah it's
definitely a good thing and
i mean i mean it's one of our topics
later on right but when you look at a
game like anthem going away
and this kind of looking looking like
that type of game but not being that
type of game
exactly i mean i don't even mention
anthem it is it's definitely one of
those things where it's like okay
they they got it right they didn't they
didn't hop on that bandwagon too late
and then realize
as they're going to release the game you
know five years later after the
zeitgeist said no this is not the thing
anymore
nobody's going to gravitate to this so
i'm glad for that because i don't want
to see another game just die
like i i really don't i we'll get into
that later on hold on let me give a
shout out to 108 dragons tv
in the dragon's den uh uh podcast yo go
check it out uh
he he's check it out see what you like
about it
uh talk to him let him help craft this
show
uh into what he wants it to be yeah he
needs feedback
he wants eyes on it and please go check
it out go check it out 108 dragons he's
a friend of the realm he's a family
member
so just just go go check it out and see
what you like about it
yeah and give feedback if you want one
of the most charismatic dudes period
in the entire community like he'd be
he's out there yeah that's my dude he
was rocking that onesie too did you see
the video with you
i told him i told him
don't ever get on tick tock again he
shouted me out he was like go to hell
um but he went to my party last night i
was in a party like around three o'clock
in the morning he jumped to my party
last night whispering
yo did you see uh
i'm like why are you whispering
[Music]
all right so let's let's get these we
have a bunch of super chats thank you
guys so we'll go back to smitty smith
with the 10
super chat jim ryan hey smitty can i
talk to you for a moment smitty sure man
what's on your mind
jim ryan man i'm bringing the whole
slate of ps5 games to pc
committee and the truth shall make you
free
somebody has too much time on his hand
oh my god he really does have too much
time on his hands
i love him then let's give a big shout
out and put the crush
in the chat for drunken ninja welcome to
the realm sir
thank you so much brother thank you much
appreciate it
then we got perfect shogun with a little
smoke gentlemen let's behave
shout out to the heartless coward that
called me a sensitive and then reported
me for jokes and got my account banned
of recovery lord cog gentlemen let's
behave
all of us it's all jokes this is what
happens when
when escalating conversations happen in
the chat
and you take it to places it need not go
it's fun
it's games it's jokes let's keep it
there
if we see anything out of pocket in our
chat you know
we're just striking it so please behave
it's all love
especially especially in the realm it's
all love so stop it
then we got cac daddy with the 5 super
chat since final fantasy was brought up
final fantasy 12 has the worst combat
system in the series
thoughts anybody final fantasy 12. he
definitely does
he's telling the truth he's telling me
then we got something else
he's he's not he's not lying there man
he's not lying
i don't like this whispering addict i
don't know
he gotta rest his voice gotta rest his
voice when he really needs it
he got that asmr voice
yes i'm gonna mute my mic after that one
here only fans in coming from attic
let's go
we got regulator regulator with the two
dollars we were chat hit the like button
for the best sunday podcast thank you
sir much appreciated
then we got raiden blade welcome to the
realm sir put the crest in the chat for
raiden blade thank you so for calling me
an old man yes my glasses are on i am
officially in the bushes today
i uh have no
i have no shame today i can't see a damn
thing
[Music]
then we got raiden blade with the five
pound super chat thank you sir
hey king can i finally make a comment in
color and join the family well yes you
have so we appreciate that
then we got the ever bored saga with the
two dollar super chat what's good party
people get well soon [ __ ] thank you
brother
and thank you for all that merch
fantastic as king was saying
it's the fastest shipping he's ever
gotten in his life
his shipping is the most amazing yo um
i don't know was blaze hill blaze wasn't
here when i um gave a shout out to
everyone so i don't know if you watched
last week
again guys i'm gonna tell you every
morning saga go check it out fantastic
he was i guess last week uh he has comic
books he has merch
uh he's building a great fantastic
ecosystem
uh blaze go check him out i know you're
gonna love the dude
you've seen him on twitter and in the
timelines
he's very conscious uh but he's making a
video game and
uh the brother needs our support um i'm
part of his kickstarter
uh so uh please guys and um i did it
under my daughter's name
because i want my daughter to
understand that wherever you are in this
life because i told her to watch the
episode
keep your dreams alive no matter what
and his story about his he was driving
to the city and his friend in the car
and his friend
you know had something on him his life
could have took a different turn
yeah without and it's much different
that's the dude with the windows when he
made it on the windows phone
yeah yes wow okay yeah yeah yes
you know now right yeah yeah i was
watching i was watching yeah so
definitely uh you know go so please
support you know just
i don't care if you go buy anything if
don't even if you don't super chat today
or whatever you don't do
just you know just you know find 20 in
your college questions like i said last
week
and go get the comic book cause i i
swear i know it's gonna be worth
something in this lifetime or even if
you're just doing it just to
read it and support great story yeah
absolutely great great story
it's when you think about the work that
it takes to
create an entire world and lore for all
these characters
backstory origins like that
you know my head hurts just thinking
about the amount of work that went into
that
and the fact that he's finally realizing
it on so many fronts they talk about
comics
anime of games like that is crazy man
that is crazy big up to everborn for
sure
um let's get the rest of these super
chats
uh we got slow mo with the five dollar
super chat without writers
yeah yeah outriders like anthem the
powers are the main way to do combat
your guns are secondary the guns are
important when your skills are on
cooldown
that's cool i like that yeah i like that
i want to know his real opinion on it
being that he's a division head
i really want to know his real opinion
on it
i i thought he was going to go a little
bit i thought he's going to come for me
be honest with you
i caught him in the chat when you were
speaking king and he said
uh he said hell no he didn't agree i
don't think
yeah yeah he's a super fan for that he's
probably staying there i guess
yeah he's yeah he's not going to slow
mo's direction
and the side he's always on is whatever
is against destiny
then we got the raider blade once again
with the five pound super chat
i love the midweek podcast with gaz and
asa love you guys history always fire
also hide us out thank you sir and the
rest of today's cast
uh listen man if you like midweek
podcasts uh j
just stay tuned that's all i have to say
stay tuned
then we got stitch with the five dollar
super chat it's all fun and games until
you can't download cod on your ps5 dad's
move ryan's
the book of acts
smith we gotta get to that ah then we
have the living flame with two dollar
super chat i'm just saying
kenna will be a true banger on pc
facts wow
beautiful beautiful but the caveat was
pc
yeah yeah but it looks it looks gorgeous
i'm super excited for that game
yeah the cutscenes look great
he said have fun on epic yeah yeah you
better have that
launcher and we got smitty once again
smitty on fire today with the 10
super chat i would like to share some
words of comfort of playstation nation
um that so passionately shared with us
for a while exclusives
just build the pc there's no need for a
playstation oh my god but it's the
opposite it's definitely the opposite
okay yeah all playstation dudes have a
powerful pc remember
i'm getting sick man i need yeah he's
like
what's up man the all playstation news
have a serious ring it's getting very
very smoky in the room very smoky a lot
of smoke
last moment all right as for me of
course lord stop iop
uh host if coerced as always to host the
show you know
it's always i'm not the co-host with the
como's but here i am you know
so but i appreciate uh cogs confidence
in me
um so this week i didn't get a chance to
play
damn near anything it's been a crazy
week as my weeks usually are
but uh yesterday i had uh i had my
nephew staying over with us and i
haven't seen him or spent significant
amount of time with him for a while just
because of cover trying to you know stay
distance or whatnot
but he stayed with me last night and
he's he his thing is
justin well no justin is a man already
this is the this is the baby so this is
about the baby baby yeah he's eight
all right let's let's okay so
this is how long ago i haven't seen
because i've never seen this baby
yeah you've never seen this baby yeah so
i remember
justin when we was going to get gays and
he'd be like yo
like you must be theo theo like oh yeah
for sure it was
they love me and this one this one is
the same way because he knows when he
comes here
he's going to have a smorgasbord of
things to play because right
i mean because my sister's very she
doesn't like letting him have a lot of
electronics she likes them to go out and
stuff like that and she doesn't
and she doesn't want to bother with
balancing it so
you know his he has his 3ds and i got
them a couple of the other mini consoles
but beyond that like a couple of years
ago i got them both
uh switch lights my niece and my nephew
the standstills yeah the and uh
my sister was like take him back take
him back take him back out
consumed yeah so so when he comes to
visit which is rare these days i like to
have him you know
he i let him rock out so but he wanted
to play with me so i got to i
sat down and played uh some mario
odyssey with him
um so that was fun because he like he
likes being cappy for whatever reason he
rather i do the platforming stuff
and then we threw on the uh mario 3d
world and
he loved bowser's fury and i hadn't even
looked at bowser's fury yet
bowser's fury unto itself like it's it's
straight up 3d mario
let me let me give a shout out since you
said that um
let me give a shout out to microsoft
destroying nintendo's hustle
house this is this i've purchased this
game on wii u
i'm forced to purchase it again on
switch
microsoft with the velocity architecture
and the boost and everything in your
games or growing with you in your
library where your games will always be
fresh again
especially uh first party games
i don't ever have to do this crap again
on a not one platform and
that's nintendo's whole hustle and
everything
and they're never going to be called out
yo because they're so used to doing
their own thing
see sony's would get called out for that
not nintendo dude
i mean i and i call my own fraud like
they they don't know i purchased it
right
you see me right yeah you feel i'll be
gone i got both too
yeah how do you feel about this people i
mean
come on i'm fine with it i've gotten
over it
not me i don't do it i i speak up about
it i'm like no
it's it's it's crazy they're doing that
with the skyward sword as well
and that's where it's the same
oh yeah it looks the same it definitely
looks the same maybe a little smoother
you know maybe a little bit smoother but
no they nintendo is always going to get
away with this because they keep
buying it it's always top of the charts
and pre-sales pre-orders and and
you know i don't do it but it doesn't
stop them
good on you i'm talking out about it
but look at me blaze yeah look at that
look at look at
all of us from my hypocrisy
thank you nintendo but yeah it's
disgusting i can't wait till it's
completely destroyed and
thrown away and they have to adapt to
but i think out of all of them nintendo
will
never been the knee yeah never
never and not even if you sort of not
even if you sort of see
the industry trying to force them to do
it it's not going to matter i just
honestly don't think it's going to
matter
um i'll get the two more super chats we
got slow-mo backslap with the 5
super attack king i can see outriders
stealing division players because they
won't get division content
until later this year but they could
take destiny people too
let me address something in the chat
there's like some giant war going on
between chris hart and a couple people
come on guys i understand that you guys
don't like each other etc etc
it's like but let's keep it civil like i
keep seeing people getting timed out and
stuff like the mods are going to handle
you so you might as well just be so
civil like yes
let me chris it's all this is all fun
games and jokes guys we're talking about
games like i don't see how
hey y'all y'all want to push christopher
hart away
and i'm going to tell you this right now
christopher hart stays on my timeline
he stays here he goes on today he's in
this chat and he's
repping where a lot of people don't
first
respect his rep that's one two your game
on one platform that's fine you're no
better than christopher hart
trust me when i tell you this because if
you lock yourself away from that
playstation ecosystem
and you're just bashing the playstation
you're doing the same thing that he's
doing
so if you have a playstation put it up
there give him
a thumbs up because he's still your
brother he's still playing games
but let's try to turn him into an xbox
head
let's keep
let's get on to the topic yes sir yeah
we're going on
let me get these super chats real quick
um then we got jonathan lopez with the
five dollar super chat hey king i'm
playing super lucky's tales but can i
figure out i can't figure out how to
change it to 120 fps
i have a c10 in series x love you guys
oh yeah get out some of the c10 owners
in on twitter
so maybe you might not have your uh
your hdmi in the right slot because
don't it's it's a
uh one no no no no no no not on the
scene
yeah so it's it's probably a setting
that you don't have set
in your console i'm pretty sure the uh
that program works automatically i don't
think you need to turn anything on or
off
okay okay oh um yeah cause the hdmi 2.1
should read
everything that your tv is capable of
outputting so
my special slot i you know i'm not privy
to
all of that and i'm not going to buy
another television until my 10 grand
television dies
yeah we got smitty smith two dollars
super chat nintendo
hurry up and buy again yeah
[Applause]
man i'm buying that new pokemon game
well not new i'm buying the old pokemon
game broadcast
with a nice little nice coat of paint i
showed my nephew that he is a big
pokemon fan and he lost his damn mind
like i love i love diamonds so i i'm i'm
i think it's called brilliant diamond i
don't know what it's called
but whatever it's called it's going to
be in my switch
brother
once again with the five dollar super
chat nintendo is the kaiser sauce
of the gaming industry i always picture
the switching up their limp and walking
straight at the end of every direction
i bet you there's a lot of people in the
chat that didn't get there
yeah you know that's old people talk
that's fine
[Laughter]
no doubt so uh for me yeah ending it up
one one last little retro thing
so cog and i have been following for the
longest time this wrestling game called
retro mania yes sir
retro oh yeah and of course king so this
is the spiritual successor to the old
school
uh wrestle fest games and wwf wwf
superstars in the arcade like beautiful
pixel art games like
the characters look fantastic the
gameplay was was super fun
and it was a quarter muncher so this
game called retro mania is especially
spiritual successor to that and it was
supposed to launch across all platforms
this week
but they got held up a little bit and
sort of uh insert
so only the steam version came out and i
could not wait so i just i downloaded it
i have not played it yet it looks
bonkers though so i'm hearing some good
some bad
stuff uh it seems like it seems like
they they stayed too close to the
control sort of scheme of the old games
rather than maybe sort of updating it to
feel maybe more like the the hockey
games that we used to love on the n64
but in terms of look and in terms of
animation in terms of the craziness of
the uh
the the matches and stuff it looked kind
of bonkers so and it's a game that's
going to continue to evolve and grow
so i picked it up on steam i'll have
more to say about it next week but i'm
excited to play because i love those
games i know king loved those games and
cog we
absolutely adored those games so so that
is that
so before we get into our topics uh just
uh
uh a note of seriousness um one of you
guys
have heard but uh guys lord dizzy is not
well
nor dizzy is not doing well so if you
can
in his timeline on twitter on his wife's
uh timeline on twitter lady roslyn if
you guys have that uh
i don't know king or or addict if you
have that you can put it in the chat
send your love send your your good
thoughts your good vibes their way
um dizzy and his family
are so deserving of a break from all the
bs that has been going on
and the struggles that he's had
personally with his health the past
couple of years
um so anything we could send his way
love
caring good thoughts excellent vibes
just send it his way
it would be greatly appreciated so thank
you guys
on that that's absolutely
for sure it is we're thinking about you
we're thinking about you brother we you
have
we're you're in our prayers man you're
definitely in our prayers brother
all right so let's get to these topics
and for anybody who
ever said that we don't talk about
playstation
this is the show for you so
our first topic is playstation games
coming to the pc now this is actually
part of my topic
so i will jump in so
in an interview published earlier this
week
um playstation head jim ryan indicated
that morgan that's not his name that's
not his thing i
i don't know he doesn't follow my crap i
don't follow i don't follow the creed i
i just don't i don't call the man out
his name not yet anyway
no he's not lying ryan yeah
there's so many there's so many garbage
pail kids like that you can make out of
jim ryan right now
it is crazy it's crazy so um in an
interview published
published in british gq um jim ryan made
it clear that many more games from the
playstation catalog were going to make
their way to pc
beginning with days gone this spring
right and uh
obviously with the release of horizon
zero dawn last year
last august i believe to the pc platform
they already showed that they were
willing to move their games over
to the to the pc platform because
monetarily it makes sense
uh these are fantastic games by by most
accounts
um and you want them to reach as many
people as possible and quite frankly
there are plenty of people out there who
don't
want to get a playstation people game on
pc solely and don't don't really bother
with the console market
so this makes monetary sense um but
obviously
it has rubbed some people the wrong way
uh
you know the some some heavy duty
playstation faithful
had some serious things to say about
this shout out to day bari bari
vari my man bari had a bit of a
breakdown um
on but but i will say this he
he held the line he held the line and he
made his points for why
he feels it's a bad move and i got to
give him props for that because
you know where a lot of other people
have said that this is a bad deal for
getting your playstation games going
elsewhere
um and now sort of move the goal post as
as the the heads of playstation move the
goal post you gotta
you either run with it or you don't so
my question to you guys is what do you
feel about this
was it inevitable um after seeing
horizon zero dawn come
and ultimately what do you think this
means for
the playstation as a platform does it is
it devalued in the way that some people
are saying
or does it just allow it to grow more so
let me go with playstation nations
fighters first blaze 4k what are your
thoughts on this blaze
listen this guy jim right listen he's
not a fan listen i don't want to i don't
want to
catch anything seriously i'm not even
joking look
jim ryan like i said the guy looks i've
been telling people
if you look at him he really looks like
he got bit by a clicker man
the guy oh my goodness so much this is
not good for
playstation playstation listen i
understand they want to get
they're leaving money on the table bro i
get it man right they want to make money
financially it makes sense but listen
look at nintendo nintendo will not budge
they keep their ground they will not
port their games nowhere are you buying
a nintendo switch and that's it yeah you
can emulate emulate man it's not the
same i don't want to hear
right jim ryan is doing this and he's
saying more games than cabral he's on g
first of all you're on gq bro what are
you doing on g2 giving like these state
like this guy
i don't like jim ryan man i don't like i
don't like it for this reason because
the brand playstation listen i know a
lot of people that are skipped on the
series x why
because they already got a pc and they
can have they can play their games
on pc with playstation good
just out of curiosity please just just
for the the courts for the for the
iop courts uh i think i've heard you on
multiple occasions
say the only thing preventing you from
buying a series x is a
is a bet with kofi correct
where's that quote that quietness going
on
i can't hear you yeah real quick
normal blade slow-mo wants to know when
when god will warn spider-man and go
into pc
oh that's the thing that's the thing
listen mark my king you want to make a
bet with me i love you bro
uh okay listen listen spider-man god of
war
first i'm i'm going to allow eric take
erica to get to her house
no problem i'm willing to take all your
bets trust me
you know what it is he's going to take
your lunch money man
all of this the same way i told hip-hop
which he was definitely afraid of my bet
you know about the launch titles and
even if he kept the bet he was still
lost
brother i'll take all your money but let
me just say this statue
let me just say this like i don't think
playstation
playstation is pop culture man i feel
like
you know they really think they're
the thing is when you see playstation
making these moves that are in parallel
to sort of what microsoft's doing right
in their own way
don't you feel though like and we just
finished saying how nintendo would not
have to bend the knee in this way
right and it is because they they're
perceived as this company that's doing
their
own thing and when you talk about the
main sort of
argue the main sort of gaming b for
argument
it's playstation and xbox so even though
you know in a lot of ways nintendo's are
selling both of them like
but they are doing their own thing and
they're not sort of beholden to what
these two companies are doing in the
same way that these co
two companies you know playstation and
xbox are beholding to one another
so it's like it almost feels like if one
of them is doing something that
is successful and and again like
xbox takes a lot of flack for for sort
of being the first to do certain things
and
and it not being popular and then it
becoming sort of the norm
now with with playstation sort of going
this route you know baby steps going
this route and doing that thing it just
sort of feels like they
have to like if they continue to sell
games in the way that they've done in
the past when it comes to like they're
leaving a considerable amount of money
on the table not just some money
they're leaving an insane amount of
money on the table
because when you think about hey i'm
going to pay for this game
70 one time right or do you
create some sort of some sort of
subscription model where you're paying
me fifteen dollars twenty dollars a
month
for god knows how long and at the end of
the day when you calculate all that
you've paid me
for that seventy dollar game ten times
over you know what i mean like
at the end of the day that argument
because they're they're
always considered to be you know their
competition is xbox and xbox's
playstation competition
it's one of those things like you can't
divorce them from one another so they
kind of have to do
things that are in the same vein and i
don't think i don't think being that
different from each other
is going to work for them moving forward
in terms of the money
discussion so i i just don't know if
that that's a reality
i know i know people want to keep it
that way but i don't know if it's really
a reality moving forward
let's solve like i asked yesterday on
scumcast right i said
i said you got a series x he's like nah
i'm like why not he's like
because i don't need it i got a pc i was
like but you got a playstation he's like
yeah
it just it just looks like yes who on
scumcast
slo-mo all right okay
that mentality for that is appropriate
in in the sense of saying that uh
you know you're able to play here
now that was set up a long time ago that
took growing pains that took heat that
took steps
that took a narrative to know what the
future had in front of them
right and a lot of people did not want
that to come to pass
now i'm not going to jump into your
segment but i understand
his logic from that point
where i have a powerful pc that i paid
five to six thousand dollars for
that i can gain with my xbox here
playstation is unwilling to do this
i don't know what is the problem with
people feeling that they don't have to
spend
500 for a barrier of entry if you paid 5
000
you should already have that entry into
the to to whatever those games is
but i don't want to jump into that part
because i don't want to give my hand
but that's you know i'm just saying i
think when it comes to devaluing the
plays they should run it does
i mean if you give less incentive for
certain people to buy a console it's
definitely devouring it but the question
is
is
the brand because the brand's still
going to be on pc regardless
but at the end of the day like it does
devalue the console but
i i honestly feel like the people it
devalues for
such a small demographic that it doesn't
matter like the majority of people
buying these playstations
they're buying it for the maddens
they're buying it for the the 2ks
they're buying it for
well i mean for the show i guess call of
duty like
they're not anymore they're not that's
gonna be
y'all gonna hate me that day they're
they're not sitting there when they go
to game stopper look on the story is
this on pc
eighty percent of those people don't
even know if it's on pc like
like they know that this there is
how many people you think's out there
like the kofis the erikas the
the bgs it's very small the majority of
people are console gaming
now obviously we have a lot of people
that's that's on these
media outlets like steam all you have to
do is make an account in your registered
account on there
like when it comes down to it sony and
microsoft knows
i could put my stuff my stuff on there
and it's going
they were going to buy my cup my game
anyway so now they can buy it on there
sure they don't buy the console and you
know it does take people out of the
ecosystem
and i will say i don't want to cut you
out brother
this is my problem what i got this is
this is why i hate these
right listen days gone is trash day's
gone it's midnight's gone it's the worst
place in this season
i didn't get a chance to play and i was
very interested in that game but i know
blaze loves that game yeah
yeah i want that to be the narrative for
the game like well i'm not saying it's
your narrative but okay
i've always co-signed it i always
co-signed it and i said it was
it was a decent game bro it's not as bad
as yeah i mean it's right
right but hold on one second but then
right all the same guys that said it was
trash
now i got 40 people on steam it's on
their wishlist all of a sudden
wow the game is trash but now you want
it on now you're willing to play it on
it you see see but
my thing is did you block them blaze i'm
not like them yet obviously
my thing is shouldn't you be happy that
that you know days gone will bring in
more revenue if it goes to pc
uh-huh her shirt is alright because the
homie because i do feel like
the red line it's it's like it's like i
told you it's like i told you uh
blaze i agree with you it devalues the
console there's no denying that when you
give an
option to not buy the console it's
devaluing the console
but it's like i asked it's like i said
earlier how many people is it
re-devaluing like
i i don't think it's a lot like i don't
like i think if you took
the people that have a console and the
people that have a pc and they're being
forced to buy a console
how many people on pc want to play
playstations games but they are not
buying a call
it's funny because you look at you look
at a quote that jim ryan may
had said and it was one of those things
when he said when we looked at the
reaction to horizon zero dawn
we didn't see an adverse reaction just
like you said addict because
the he wasn't listening to the loud
minority on twitter like he wasn't like
he ignored it
like he just that's not who they're
listening to
uh they're they're happy to have the
hardcore there because the hardcore
is the one are the ones that sort of
propagate the message of playstation
right
but at the end of the day this is they
always gonna go to where
the most bodies are that's it and you
know what sweaty haircut like
i think you remember this back in the
day what we're seeing now
of the a lot of the playstation fanboys
is what was happening
when quantum break went to pc you know i
don't
like a lot of people have this mentality
that they don't think that
sony would ever put themselves in a
position to make games day and day but i
don't think that
like i think the moment a playstation
game comes out like a god award it sells
two or three
two to five million on steam they're
gonna look
man i don't know like we
we should maybe i think we need to come
back and we need to it's never happening
look all i have to say please is that
man said future games he didn't say in a
way that made it seem like it wasn't
going to eventually be day and day
he said future titles
all right well that could be that could
be taken two ways it's either like
future titles coming out maybe day and
date or it's just future
in the future these games coming out
that's how i kind of took it but
yeah but that's what i was going to ask
blaze about day and date
you don't think it's happening blaze
like ever listen bro
ever already started listen if i ever
see
a game come day and date i swear to god
listen to me bro i swear on my kids
i will take every playstation i own bro
i will i will bless you
you already started i mean yeah they're
smaller and not in less significant
games in ps plus
which i already started listen listen
when you see
look your first one you're not you guys
are listening you guys are getting all
our shovel weird mid-tier vlog
you're not going to get god of war mark
my words look at it record me so
so hold up so hold up hold up hold up
hold up hold on please
please blaze hold up hold up i got a
place i got him hold
hold up blaze so right now you're
telling me
that god of war will never see the light
on pc
no you're not saying that you're saying
that oh you saying day and day are you
saying god
no no it didn't come no no god of war
right now is not coming too the one
right now ever
ever no okay hold up hold up hold up
hold up hold up hold up hold up
hold up blaze i gotta take your knees on
this let's do a bend the knee right now
like no cuz cuz like this is like this
is like a future knees being shipped to
me
like it's it's it's it's like you're
voluntarily giving me your knees
so let's do this why is this why why
these
the british are coming bro why why what
blaze if you've seen this happening
already
why why would you single out god of war
is the game that's not gonna go
yeah why that one listen man
if somebody wants to give away like
like listen you can drive my bike you
can drive my skateboard but you're not
touching my bmw
you get what i'm saying like you can't
like listen man
listen this i own a ps3 king david you
own a ps3 right no
i don't know i don't own
no old console okay i'm on to the next
thank you microsoft for saving me
and back up i'm still trying to take i'm
still trying to take blazes these on
i'm telling you why i do i own ps3s ps2s
360s i own all of them i have them all
plugged in you know why
so i can go back and play those games
that are not available
well take your whole uh xbox ecosystem
and throw it in the bushes
because all you need is a series s and
you will you will save yourself a lot of
time
and wires and old resolution all right
you we have is this thing called boost
mode right it just came out
and what you can do is you can have your
series s
or x and you can play all those same old
games that you got there
and most of them got boost right so they
they boost forward and you can throw
that stuff out you know what
michael are you giving him an xbox
tutorial
i love how you're acting like he doesn't
know too like
like i mean you're saying four games now
but we got 500 back to patch straight
off the rip
okay i can't even though is boosted
okay but not all of the games are back
compatible like there's still games that
i own that are not back compat like
they're still good
blaze no i have a question for blaze
though because blaze you play on pc
you're you're all about pc so whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa what are you doing bro why are you
shouting
why are you setting me up what's going
on no no we literally play rogue company
together
on pc oh is that i'm on playstation man
okay
i don't know if you're saying you just
don't believe god of war is coming or
you don't want
because why wouldn't you want it to come
yeah i mean like years later
slow mo ass someone asked uh blaze is
horizon zero dog
mid-tier garbage so it's like if there's
only mid-tier garbage coming i can
explain that though
okay i don't want to hit that i don't
want a handy decimal engine
uh you know i don't hear about that okay
well then i won't talk
[Laughter]
because if it's not day and date right
it would come out like like what they've
been doing so far is like the game comes
out like 2017 2018 it comes out in 2020
21 on pc
like a couple year gap there i don't
that wouldn't really necessarily hurt
three years you know look i i know you i
know what you're saying if god
ends up coming or the uncharted
collection right i underst like i get it
there's money why not play it at a high
frame who cares right but yeah
more than anything i i still don't
believe they'll give you spider-man
you know i really don't like out of all
the games spider-man because now they
own the movie rights and all that yeah
you're feeling pretty confident about
that man you feeling confident enough
with your knees
man it's about it's about that almighty
dollar man they made it very clear they
don't care about us they don't they
don't they care and that's the thing
they they've taken advantage of a lot of
microsoft missteps to
to come off as like the good guy both of
these companies hate your guts i know
they will all they want is your money
like
you know money they just you know at
different times each of them
sort of steps on the rake and it's left
swab about it
but they both just want your money and
they want you there right
um i don't know man erica finish your
point
because this is crazy i mean no i was
just you know getting to a point of like
if they aren't
day and date which i do think it can
get to there i i don't believe never
because a lot of people are like they're
never happening ever i'm like really
because the climate is changing and
microsoft
is is to credit for that i mean in a way
because they do things first
it's successful game pass is successful
right and they're making money
i think they've made i think they're
whatever reports came out they made a
bunch of money lately
and playstation like you guys are saying
if they are
never going to be like divorced in that
way they're a competition against each
other like sony's gonna look at that
money too at some point and if the
climate changes
and everything's going digital
everything's going to pc
i can't say never like it's gonna happen
but erica if you're
if you're on top listen when you're
looking down that little mic you're like
hey
you said little microphone
blaze the reason why i got to tell you
you got to stop 20 million soul is
telling you right now calm down bro
see the thing is listen the fight is
over
yeah yeah you punch drunk right now the
fight is over there is no
fight two million playstation now
subscribers versus 20 million
uh game pass subscribers it was 18. it
was 18.
it was 18 that wasn't 20 million it was
18. listen listen
i'm not arguing i hear you saying that
listen i i give him you know it's been
it's been a month and a half i'll give
him the 20 now i'll give it
erica okay i just before i go in because
i'm about to tear this the whole famous
thread
i'm sure you already know did did you
get everything that you wanted out of
this
uh this topic this part right here for
yourself because i want your voice to be
supremely heard because
king is about to hijack the conversation
so he wants to make sure you get
everything up yes
you represent a demographic that they
act like as a unicorn you are a female
gamer
that is mostly multifaceted that you
game on xbox pc
and playstation right and and some
nintendo
um well probably a lot of nintendo but
you are the voice that they really want
to hear so i
really want your input to be heard
because
the chat you really need to hear her
input because she
is what they're looking for i'm the
unicorn
i guess i'm playing on everything well
like i was kind of saying with blaze you
know because i i play a lot of pc too
so for me i think it's great like i know
horizon zero dawn didn't really work out
so well kind of
launched you know kind of buggy or
whatever but if i can get god of war on
this thing if i can get
you know last of us factions you got to
say spider-man you got to say spider-man
i won't say spider-man say spider-man
bloodborne
i need it on pc i need 60-plus frames
like
they really don't want to give us that
they just don't feel like giving us that
they want to forget about bloodborne
yeah that's the one something
something's weird with that
yeah the weird and the thing is it makes
the most sense like
it should be on with better frame rates
but anyways um
so for me i'm open to it because i like
playing on pc it's convenient for me as
a streamer and as a content creator
because everything's just here
like i'm good um but for like the
average console gamer like i think you
guys mentioned it before like is this
gonna hurt
the brand in some way like i don't think
so because the console gamers are gonna
get consoles no matter what they're not
thinking about pc
they're not they're not wanting to spend
a thousand dollars to build a pc they
don't even know the first thing
how to even do it they don't know a
thing
you know more than a thousand dollars
you know yeah and my my uncle for
example a big xbox dude
big xbox guy i talked to him about pc
constantly i'm like listen you got to
build a pc
has he done it doesn't do it he doesn't
want to do it
so there's there's a lot of those guys
and girls and and people who just
don't care about pc so even if this does
go day and date
playstation i think uh addict you said
it's like pop culture no blade said it
like a pop culture kind of thing
playstation
i think the biggest issue i think the
biggest issue erica
and you know you know i i invented attic
world but like a lot of people
a lot of people want to act like their
opinion is the end-all be-all
and just because they are gaming on pc
they want to act like everyone's gaming
on pc
that's just not the reality and it's and
it's the same and the same goes true for
console gamers a lot of times we talk
about things in our own bubble
and we don't realize how small that
bubble really is it is very
true though we are in a bubble to eloqua
your point
i have a severe gaming pc that is to my
right right here
i'm talking about to the hilt attic
knows
like one of the only games he's ever
played on is among us
i'm upset that the day that i played
among us that it came out on
xbox i wanted to choke at it because i
purchased it and i got my money back
but um and i also play like you got your
five bucks back
five bucks back the hell yeah you got
your feet screw that small developer
[Music]
yes
we got 450 people in here watching man
like definitely hit that like button if
you guys
don't mind ever i don't care
to game on my pc i don't care what the
hell you put there
i don't care what's going on i don't
they have not forced me to bend the knee
in that aspect
and i'm gonna get to your point blaze
that you you're gonna be surprised what
i say with this topic
but um let's get to these super chats
real quick because before we have
probably like they they're definitely
back yeah
we have we have yeah people are animated
in the chat to say the least we have a
smitty smith with the five dollars
we chat with the playstation captains
lieutenants and soldiers still count
consoles still
the book of x there's smitty's on it
he's on it pixel bit g five dollar super
chat it's time for gamers to grow up the
console market is capped at 250 million
users across
all platforms for three generations
either expand or go extinct
that is true like that that does make a
lot of sense
you know sometimes you know people look
at things as this phil
spencer says and like oh whatever you
still haven't given us games or whatever
the case may be
but but the idea for expanding gaming
across the board you know when you know
reaching 8 billion gamers like
that's that's a real that's the idea
that really is the i know what else
you know what else probably really hurt
like that whole transition thing
fortnight like when fortnite was out
there was console people
building pcs because they wanted to play
fortnite at the best they possibly could
exactly exactly hold on let me uh copy
this one more super chat because we got
a bunch
yeah i gotta get these before i even
before you jump in yeah
so um okay then we have philly eagle
with the 10
super chat being upset over them making
a decision to increase their revenue is
stupid
fanboys don't matter been saying it for
years drink some tea and get over it or
play on that pc y'all claim to have
wow okay yeah that is true all the
playstation people they all got pcs to
play the xbox games
you could play xbox yeah a lot of people
do say that like i don't need an xbox
one
yeah a lot of them are lying they are
yeah little pc
then we got ksrt with the 20 super chat
sony uses the playstation brand to
weaponize some people
uh bet next year console sales will no
longer matter because dance moves said
so
let's open our eyes here putting games
on pc is a good move now the people now
the cheaper
feel it's cheaper yes because he's right
they're cheap
the tcl uh community is is not about
that
then we got uh sweeties before the five
dollars to all the playstation faithful
i would like to say welcome to the pc in
microsoft
thank you and you're welcome the book of
two x
then we have hold on jd gamer 10
super chat it's not just the money left
on the table
it's the entire markets left on the
table the worst thing you can do is let
your competition enter a market and you
not meet them
uh there to compete uh leave them to
compete alone all of the xbox one and
the ps4
no jd now people are gonna play
microsoft don't say that
but it's very true it's very true um
it's funny i i i used to colin moriarty
is he's a dude that talks a lot about uh
the veto right
and how sony let the video die and they
were like he was like why would you
just let nintendo have that you're the
only competition in that space why would
you just walk away from it when you know
your brand is strong and then you never
understood why
but i mean never gonna beat nintendo in
that space they were not gonna
but the psp sold over 80 million that's
yeah that's incredible
i listen i hear exactly what you're
saying but a lot of that was because
people were modding it that's
you know once but the thing about i i've
always felt
nintendo did the right thing
consolidating all of their games onto
hmm
all right hold up i think we're i don't
know if we're live yet give me a second
are we are we back
i don't i don't know it looks like we're
live
i don't know what happened there like
sometimes sometimes this stuff be weird
and you can definitely blame me
can you guys hear all of us fine because
somebody said they couldn't hear king
you can hear me christopher says i hear
one person
who do you hear that king who is it
should be
my check no volume on guests
i mean we haven't talked you can only
hear attic
can you hear me oh my thing it says they
can hear you
so yeah they hear us all you hear me
okay
now we can hear everyone okay all right
so um
hold on we gotta finish these these yeah
they they they made one unified front
you know and
i think that's the only way to do it so
uh playstation
i don't ever want them to i saw
something
this week and they were talking about
like uh giving a hint of a playstation
handheld
if they do not make it one unified front
don't mess with it leave it alone
yeah because that's the reason why
microsoft never approached that because
splitting that in in that manner is not
going to be beneficial for you at any
time especially when
like you said before all the games is on
pc you can get a pc handheld
that can play this stuff and a new one
just came out which was really good i
was talking to a guy in the background
that one is really good they don't pay
me so i'm not promoting them
but it's a really good handheld some
guys may not want to pay the six seven
hundred dollars for this handheld
and that's what it takes to really bring
these games to fruition so
uh let's get these super chats and then
we can get to my part of the segment and
we can push on guys
that's right 330 you guys are thank you
for coming back
that's what i'm talking about they just
got up you know they went to the to the
fridge they went to the bathroom you
know let me have a bathroom
no doubt we got cat daddy lurk with the
five dollar super chat days gone is mid
and when it comes to steam i'm buying it
again just to encourage somebody to
bring even more games over
i want to play games at their best no
doubt shout out for sure
and we got smitty smith with the 5 super
chat ps fanboys took sony out to dinner
and then left them with the reality
check
that is that that is good scripture for
the book of acts this guy smitty smith
is kind of
he's on it man he's pretty good with
them that's that's my dude
smitty is something else let me have
pixel bit g two dollar super chat
when they hire gym corporate pay out
ryan you knew oh my god corporate payout
these names i'm loving it they're on it
and they're on to it then we have smitty
smith again five dollar super chat
remember when it was just one game then
it turns into five
it's happening get in line iop book of x
then we have face 23 with the 15 super
chat
15 million ps plus subscribers does
microsoft mention xbox live subscribers
no they talk about active users yeah
the metrics are changing okay so you
know
50 million playstation subscribers
microsoft talks about active users
don't let them disrespect you by telling
you what the active users and
the subscribers are because you would
really cry you would really sit there in
your little bubble
and that 50 million if it comforts you
in some weird way i have no idea you're
just one
of that 50 million i don't know how it
comforts you i don't really talk mpd's i
don't really care because
when i purchase my consoles and i'm
pretty sure i'll purchase more than
a ton of you guys unless you're a
scalper at a
higher rate than me um i
really don't think you should talk
numbers you purchase one console
enjoy your one console you purchase your
one game you that one person
i go out and purchase actively i try to
buy 10 playstation 5's this year i
wanted to escalate
didn't happen it didn't happen damn you
scalpers
but again stop talking numbers that we
we don't see
you know that's their money stop
counting somebody else's money
yeah that's the show then we got big
cloud gaming we put the crest in the
chat for the
guy big thank you brother much
appreciate it
what's up baby no doubt no doubt then we
have mariano
i love him if halo infinite is what we
all want it to be and brings the bag for
game pass
will this make sony potentially think
day on date on ps now or pc
i mean i think i think it it is a
reality of
sony's waiting and seeing to see you
know
obviously the money is there right the
money argument is there you have
20 million whatever game pass
subscribers giving you 15
a month at some point yeah they may get
in the front door with
you know a one month dollar pass or a
three month dollar pass
but if they stay they're giving you that
15 a month
that adds up that that adds up so i it's
just
that's why there's doing stuff like ea
the ea play on there because they're
wanting to give you enough reason to
constantly be standing
in today no joke i've never paid more
than a dollar i always do the
three-month thing i always get offered
the three-month one-dollar always
that's what's up hey same yeah same here
that's what
and you know they've done and they do
stuff to try to they you know
this is only for new subscribers you
can't get this
you know yeah you could yeah that weighs
around it definitely weighs around it
but
more power to you if they give you those
options absolutely but a lot of people
let's say once that happens and you get
tired of looking for the for the ways
around it
like me i got my 50 i got my card on
there they're taking my 15 every month
when i get a deal
i buy the deal throw it on there and
then it just extends my
my subscription it's a great yeah it's a
great i'm compromised
some people some people legit just
purchase you know some people just legit
forget they even have it you know it's
like people who don't
like a lot of other subscriptions
shout out to my man aaron greenberg
king is bought and paid for yeah paid
for
my game pass description is to wherever
they say that i can't get any more
that's when my joint stops so the answer
to that is yes once
i mean sony's already seen it i mean
they've obviously the moves they're
making is because they've
seen it they've seen the money so it's
again it's just a matter of whether they
ever get to the point that
they're doing what microsoft is doing
exactly compliant
ksi five dollar super chat 50 million uh
ps plus true last report from microsoft
was on april 30th 2020
xbox live has 90 million monthly active
users
a lot then we have brian i 10 super chat
sony fanboys feel like
daenerys when jim ryan jon snow came up
to kiss them
he digs the playstation the pc knife in
them as he sends the dragon off to the
pc land
with all the saudi exclusives on his
back wow
that is
uh what show is that i don't know that
show anymore yeah
and died there we go oh no i doubled up
on it then we have cat daddy damn
sob you can't be hosting the podcast
with your nokia phone last warning uh
windows phone sir get it right i was
dying off of
i read this i was dying and um just i
i'm not gonna call nobody out but i i am
not the wizard behind the curtain
i'm only hosting look um
cat daddy it's totally soft it's all his
problems
wow nobody's passing the bug my way
that's okay that's fine
there we have let me see we have
the living flame with the two super chat
and the lord gave and said
let there be multiplats and we have
philly eagle five dollars super chat psa
yo fan boys the real gamers have access
to the same games
y'all have access to chill get over
yourselves and just enjoy your games
yeah it's a treat easier said than done
first for some but you know
then we have the raider blade with the
five pound super chat hi yeah i'm
looking for uh
for it pc handheld looks fire my bros
zap
lol okay i i don't i know what you're
talking about yeah i know what he's
talking about i just
didn't come out the right way
[Applause]
lord king you're up sir
your thoughts okay so uh sony games
going to pc
told you i told you right i told you
before when jim
dance moves ryan showed up he's a
numbers dude
they brought him in for a reason and
numbers wasn't up to stuff he's trying
to bring the numbers up he's in
the field dominance maximus aurelius
camp he's an understudy
from that whole bill belichick uh
all right um he has the playbook he
understands he's been grown
in this whole numbers uh thing and he's
a metrics dude
the problem that you're having with sony
is
you have two sonys you have the people
that hire jim dance move ryan to bring
the metrics up to bring them current
to show them exactly what they needed
because they saw microsoft making
tons of money how do they have
50 million consoles and their money
is if not equal to hours more than hours
and we have 120 million consoles sold
how can we
shore up this money where are they
getting money from show us how they're
doing this
so the other heads at sony they still
going by the archaic
uh console sold uh metrics
they think that the npd's mean anything
that is just
fuel for the fanboys that's all that is
i had they have 120 million sold you
only brought one what what
what do you really mean in that whole
ecosystem
you don't buy all the games because if
you did buy all the games if
120 million of the so-called consoles
that was out there
if every person brought god of what it
would be 120 million god awards sold
that is not the case there's money on
the table how do they get to this money
there's money's in the pc realm i i hate
the fact that every time i hear
a playstation dude say i don't need a
xbox console because i have a pc
you're still in the console you it's
still in their ecosystem microsoft has
done this
to make sure that you wherever you want
to game if it's on your cell phone
if it's on your console if it's now on
your televisions
wherever you want a game you can gain
there
for playstation to survive
they must port those games over to pc
that is god of war that is spider-man
that is you start with days gone you
guys laughed
at me when i told y'all before that it's
gonna happen
it doesn't affect you if you purchase
the game already right did it affect me
really
once uh nintendo decided to do this to
me
and i already had it i already had the
game so i had a choice i could stay pat
and i can just play it here
i can just boot up my wii u or
i can purchase the game on another
platform that i actually game on
with a little bit of resolution boost
and stuff like that pc is no different
sir
the pc is no different if the game
horizon zero dawn
is uh playable on the pc
higher resolutions better texture
filtering all this other stuff
it makes no problem to the playstation
owner that doesn't want a pc
but the pc gamer that doesn't want a
console game because he paid five
thousand dollars for his pc he has the
opportunity to partake in what you're
doing
they have to become a publisher i told
you when
sony became a publisher you were in dire
straits
because at that point in time that means
that those games could go
anywhere for them to receive that money
for them to stay viable
in this space in this gaming space they
must be diverse and if you want them to
be restricted that's
you you restrict yourself but you cannot
restrict the billion dollar company you
know king
if you look at the way that they did the
studios
where they started um you know i
wouldn't say going away from the
playstation brand
but they started like when they
restructured the studios
i i i think people should have looked at
that because they're going a little bit
like you know exactly they're going to
do that you said your stream went down
who the hell dropped the stream
i'm here to police the situation
first of all i'm gonna have to do this
for you sir
off your surgery i'm gonna have to hit
you with it right all right so i want
you
i want you to first do one thing i want
you to mute your mic i don't need you
talking i don't need you animating your
face
i don't need you laughing i don't need
you listening we already busted hit all
of his stitches
his stitches is loose right now i'm past
the 48 hour bucks
okay all right um continue kick i'm
gonna hear this
as i was saying continue king
policing as i was saying jim dance moves
ryan is definitely complicit he's going
to be complicit to the point that
blaze you don't want to hear this now if
you want to be ridiculous and crazy
and say day and date will never happen
that's an open-ended bet right
because once they became a publisher
once they got down with epic this is
where
the problem lies you don't think
them having a stake in the epic store
forces their hand a day and date
and they want to make money you don't
think epic wants to beat steam
you don't think the pressure from epic
into getting games day and day on a pc
and that doesn't affect any playstation
owner at all
if you own a playstation you don't have
a gaming pc none of that stuff
matters to you if it's in the epic store
you know why because if a tree falls in
the forest
and you're not there to hear it did it
fall or not oh yeah you can
the question a question i have for
kingdom is the the consensus
i'm seeing online is people are feeling
jim ryan
kind of lied to them he lied to
everybody right so
do you think it's more of a portrayal
situation yes
that they they feel that these games
would have never come because the
reality is they only come in
three years after right i mean it comes
like years
give a boy and she gonna take the yellow
right right so you know
so to us we like okay they just set you
up for the group
what you've noticed is and i'm i'm
telling you
you hear one announcement right then you
hear the next announcement
you know what the when i knew it was a
problem when they put that crash team
racing that smash up team racing
the jump that game into playstation now
day and day
when they did day and date on that smash
team
flop game the 61 metrics that y'all like
metrics
with more releases why
i mean he's he's buttering you up that's
what i got to say do you think that is
the substitute because
ps plus that's the attack of doing day
and date with certain games in there
you know when p playstation plus
or playstation now is in the epic store
this is where your knees are shipped to
me
this is where your knees see they want
to get playstation now like game pass
how can we get these imaginary dollars
we need this this magic money
i need magic money i need to put an app
on your
device that i can get my game there and
you can purchase into this
this th this app and i can make it
viable day and date i don't care what
game it is
i don't care if you're going to tell me
it's mid-tier i don't care what you say
playstation now needs to be more viable
came out first
right it's supposed to be the superior
lead platform
why isn't it more viable than game pass
the only reason why is
one man had the vision had the
the the gumption had the kihones
to say all our first party games is
coming here day and date
no matter what he took the heat
but he was right it was a gamble that he
needed to make
let jim do his job you brought him in to
bring up the numbers to shore up the
numbers to bring this magic money in
so you guys ain't always looking at
bankruptcy you're looking at bankruptcy
every year and it's really disgusting
that you need a hit
and if a game doesn't hit then you're
worrying about the doors closing
japan
blaze you don't like what i'm saying but
sony does is turning their back on their
home country
japan is not a viable option to bail you
out anymore
the games are not selling people are
leaving that place in droves
they're closing the japanese studios
down and what is going to happen to you
without your japanese fan base that
these american people love those
japanese games
so what happens then that's what bro
it's worth the money studio it's
one studio with the money well hold on
what that one studio those
those workers are they're being
allocated to different studios
why because their studio is not viable
because that studio all they did is
assist
other other studios they weren't but
actually that that studio i mean maybe
maybe in recent years
but that studio was the lifeblood of
playstation like if you look if you look
at
japan studio and the origins of
playstation
right ps1 that studio that put
that especially from a first party
perspective it put them on the map
so it to king's point it's it's a kind
of
it it's kind of an erasing of the
heritage and sort of
going a different route jim is killing
y'all but you know hold on king but you
know
but but that studio yeah it back in the
day yeah but
you know over time they they started
doing other things but i went to monica
right that's what you're going to tell
me right
you got some tell me sony santa monica a
lot of their top studios
let's be real they bought those studios
too like they bought it listen
my problem king is not what you said the
the only problem i had out of everything
you just spewed and a lot of them were
facts
okay but the only thing i had a problem
is that place
needs to they if they don't do this
they're this and i don't feel like they
need they're going to
die they're going to die
so the question becomes the question
becomes the viability of playstation
right
i love you man
[Laughter]
i'm trying to understand your mindset
because the only point that i see what
king is saying i see where you're going
the only point i'm trying to say let's
just say hypothetically
okay if this saves the business model
let's say the old business model
is not viable going into the next
generation and if this is the way to
save it
is it an eagle thing on us as gamers to
say
a year later that this game goes over
there
i'm not saying it is i'm just i
shouldn't be i don't
even it shouldn't be i don't even think
it's it's a neces they're on that
if we don't do this we're gonna we're
gonna crash the ship thing i think their
their mindset is we this this giant
market that's on tap why are we tapping
it's just it it's right in front of you
it's right in front of you
and it's like you say like the
conversations we're having are echo
chamber conversations that we have
because we're hardcore gamers
right when you look at the vast majority
of people who own these platforms the
vast majority don't care about any of
this and they
and they will play these games wherever
they wherever they they
they find them on right if they happen
to be somebody who has a 2025 you know
3 000 pc they'll play them on pc or you
know
for a lot of people the fact that it's
exclusively on playstation doesn't mean
anything to them
here's the thing too oh
um i think with some gamers at least
from what i
kind of see the consensus i think some
of them are just afraid
console gaming is going to die at some
point but the reality is like
it's bigger than ever right now yes
pandemic
you know kind of maybe has to do with it
gaming is not dying it's not going it's
huge it's bigger than like the movie
industry right now it's so freaking huge
i saw some
the climate though and the the the
future remember for a long time we were
like no we'll never buy digital games
it's not going to take over right and
then what happens digital is freaking
huge it's the same thing going into the
next gen it's like i'll never do
streaming i'll never do pc
and then what happens i used to be a
console peasant man i was all about
console mastery console this comes with
that i don't need 60 frames
and then what happened i'm on pc
majority and you know
it changes you know just you got to go
if you're a gamer right
you want to play everything you got to
go with it or else you're going to be
left behind we always had 60. we had 60
back when we had crts when we moved from
crt yeah
to the newer televisions we got dumbed
down to different frames
and a lot of these uh guys
first i got to give i got to give
respect y'all y'all really think i cap
for uh uh phil dominus maximus really is
spencer
yeah i do daddy phil that's uncle still
right there
king almost
to say that he comes from back when
gaming was 60 frames per second crts and
stuff like that
and i was watching digital foundry and
and john lennon and my dear friend
um you know a lot of you guys don't
really like him i love him
i love him because he pointed out
when we went from crts to these lcd
television and
just different refresh rates that's when
it hurt gaming
we never needed to make that jump it
wasn't for us that was for uh
the the the fans uh that needed smaller
televisions we would carry our big back
televisions to play our games we didn't
care
the frame rates meant more to us than
anything and
you know microsoft respects the frame
rates and they're going back to that
that cinematic
thing that y'all guys is talking about
uh the sony way to cinematic way
let's stop that they can't do it the
playstation 5
is a weaker uh underpowered i can't keep
going
let's
[Laughter]
because i i got so much luck listen bro
i got every system can you know i got
four experts
of course man of course but you don't
got a series x though
that's because of uh uh you're fraud so
don't let that bet hold you back from
greatness
i won the bet i won the bet right so go
pick up your series x now
where tell me exactly it's sold out so
all you guys talking about these mpd
these numbers like the playstation is
winning you can't buy it
but you want it thank you so much
i haven't seen an xbox nowhere i gotta
be honest with you what about the s you
gotta ask
oh yes i haven't seen no xboxes no i was
able to get so many of them
you're king david i don't know
but listen listen blaze i come across
one i have you have one tonight i got
you
i'll throw you i'll cash out you bro i
got you all right all right
let's get these uh yeah we're good we
have a
topic the living which oh so which topic
is that so i can skip to it sir
the the storage storage this should be
interesting okay
happy to see you lord kyle raiden blade
with the five pound super chat thank you
sir
then we got the living flame two dollar
super chat don't push yourself [ __ ] we
love you take care
yeah cox somebody on here was talking
mad smack about how you're getting
i don't know i don't know who that was
yeah
chat vote from the ground up for the
playstation 5 the power of the ssd
we believe in generations who wants to
play old games now go play on pc what a
tangled web we win
the book away your smitty sniff is on
fire today
there we have the raiden blade once
again hold on i skipped with the five
pound super chat
i don't have time to play your own two
consoles but i'm looking forward to
seeing ps now app on xbox and it will
happen at some point
yeah hey hey stranger things strange
things have happened
all right so we're gonna get into this
next topic the ps5 storage
expansion delay uh lord king would you
like me to serve it up for you sir
yes please do so thank you so
along with the announcements of psvr2
which we'll talk about in a little bit
and the games coming to pc that's out of
the cops yeah
oh yeah boogie down in the bronx thank
you thank you look it down
there's this drama going on in the
streets
sony announced that they will not have a
solution for
ps5 uh ssd expansion until the summer
um and they're saying that the the
firmware update that will bring this to
fruition
in addition to allowing uh so the
assumption is that we're going to get
uh third-party ssds that are on par with
the internal ssd
by the summertime now along with that
they're indicating
that's going to increase fan speeds
which means this baby's going to get hot
very very hot so uh king
immediately jumped on this so if you
didn't get enough of king the last topic
you'll get a whole lot of king right now
all right so uh king this is your topic
you were very adamant about
about talking about this let's get into
it
serving up these elves
how do those knees feel
we need some numbing agents for these
knees because i want to take them with
ease
give me some knees please when i'm when
we chop them off
i want you to mail them to mount vernon
send them to westchester new york with
the king resides
money earning mount vernon we got to
change that name to knees earning mount
vernon
i told you dudes when you was capping
and slapping their knees
you know still he says super fast
baby it was super fast
you never seen an ssd
and you've never seen it because it's
not there
microsoft is selling they they they want
terabit solution
playstation come out with this solution
it's going to be cheaper you don't got a
solution
you don't have a solution you know what
the solution is shut up and wait
the solution is and you can't even go in
there and put your own in there because
it's locked out
they locked you out you got an expansion
but
yo it remind me remember who was looking
at the nintendo and they had the
expansion bay that they never used
and we had all these wild thoughts yo
they're going to put all these
shoulders like that and they're going to
do so much
all right so this is this is the
breakdown
sony was doing it in the background and
remember all the heat
dissipation that they were saying that
um microsoft was running the hot the
series x was running yes
and stuff like that when they did they
took their
studies they realized that the console
was running hot the fan noise was super
loud
he didn't want that narrative because
the playstation pro
gets really loud the playstation regular
gets really loud
so they wanted this to be a quiet system
they wanted the heat dissipation to be
great
uh so this is locked off from that right
now because they're telling you
exactly the system was overheating was
it overheating
to the point that it made failures
remember this is a juggling system
they're balancing uh power and speed
between the cpu and between the gpu
so it's not a fixed based system it is
poorly designed to be honest with you
and i think that it's coming to fruition
right about now
now the ssd
not being there hampers them in this
next generation
because we have a call of duty
and if you have to delete games off your
hard drive to
play a game or don't put certain
areas of a game just one single game
this is one single game that you can't
play
in its entirety in your playstation 5
that is a problem and now you're gonna
say but you can't do that on your series
that's
shut up and go purchase the
one terabit ssd that's available
that microsoft made sure that you didn't
have to make these compromises
in the beginning of your console
generation
you should not be limited to how you
play your games
you should be always accessible at any
time
in between because both of those are
indistinguishable in the microsoft
platform
there is no solution for the playstation
it's is egregious enough that the they
didn't go
above and beyond both manufacturers
didn't put one terabit in there but that
would have raised the cost
right the fact that you cannot have a
solution
until the summer time and they lied in
to you in the beginning they told you
one will be available
after you is is a severe bait and switch
and i don't
see enough playstation dudes
screaming and yelling that they can't
add more games because there is
zero solution because the the that's my
frustration
because the the it was kind of brought
to our attention like
there would be a whole bunch of
third-party solutions that we would be
able to use as long as we match up the
correct speed
right right we give you a list and we'll
give you a spec
so i'm like okay their their internal
in-house solution proprietary solution
isn't ready that's cool
we could use a third-party but now
you're like oh
we need a firmware update so in order
for it to work so that it doesn't so it
doesn't overheat the system so
from a design standpoint that just
sounds wild i'm not a hardware designer
but
that sounds loud yeah this sounds scary
the size of these games are so large
they're so large at least with these
series x
i have that usb 3.0 as a caddy so i'm
like okay whatever i'm not using now
that's big
transfer you know you can't do that you
have no option
so it's like i i have about four or five
games on my ps5
and i'm like damn i guess i gotta take
ghost's shield off i gotta take this one
off
because i gotta download this and it
just put it on though i'll give you
i'll give you a listen i don't wanna cut
you off look
listen first of all sony not having any
expansion is unacceptable number one
that's just ridiculous the fact and it's
like i guarantee you
when when they show what's available hey
you can buy this nvme you can buy this
one you can buy
i guarantee you some already on the
market right now but they just don't
want to do the update because they're
you know they want to make sure
yeah right are you recovering from
surgery too
oh i just don't want to get i don't want
to get listen your surgery is not up
here your surgery is below your legs
man he caught me with that like wait
wait what are you talking about
listen i was just saying how see now now
i get a defensive swing
it's unacceptable it really is bro it
really is they like i know i was mad i
was like oh
xbox got this proprietary thing like how
you guys even complaining they went
proprietary that's so bad that means if
there's nothing if there's nothing
available you have to go with xbox
that's really bad that's proprietary but
you know what
i've seen those little storage things
everywhere at target there was plenty of
them
yeah but playstation it's really
unacceptable but
there's one solution i bought an ssd and
the only good thing about it it doesn't
save sony it's not making up for their
their bad flaws
but like you said goes through sema
that's a ps4 game enhanced with ps5
features
and days gone and and call of duty
modern warfare those are huge games but
bro if you buy an ssd
you it automatically downloads to that
ssd so you're not using up your
precious ps5 so i would recommend to
anybody that got a ps5 just buy a
ssd brother right the only thing the
only thing not to cut you blaze the
problem i'm having
is if i keep my ssd connected when i do
that
i'll boot up and it'll be like oh we're
rebuilding the database
yeah this is weird crashing stuff like
like it it has this problem
that if you keep it in that sleep mode
shut up
it has that option it has that option
when it goes into sleep mode where it
asks you
if you want to turn off your storage yes
and apparently
not turning it off when you when when
updates come through or whatever
like certain things yeah they haven't
been able to pinpoint the problem
but the same thing that's why i don't
have any sort of exercise
i disconnected it because i'm like yo
i'm not going to keep booting my ps4
and every time i boot it up oh we found
the error let's rebuild the data i
love jason ronald and the team
but uh that happened uh that happened on
uh solid rev too like his ps5 was
defective he got rid of it and bought a
series x and that's it
no but as soon as i as soon as i start
disconnecting it it don't do it
it was fine yeah it just seems like you
if you put it in sleep mode
your best bet is not to have anything
connected like i've
the playstation the playstation can't
even sleep correctly that's crazy
you know what king you know what king i
think i finally found something that has
more sleeping issues than i do
it's okay i'm the ssd i got all your
playstation 4 games
get it all for me why are you here
reboot to you
hey i like how you said ps4 games i
don't have that issue at all
so anyway so it doesn't matter so so
erica
what are your thoughts on this have you
had any issues uh
i have not hooked up an ssd or any kind
of external i actually
can throw some shade on this ps5 because
it's been dusty
i don't even have enough games on there
to hit that max so
i'm not even there yet love you i've
been playing
go sushima all right here and there i
played demon souls beat that
and i'm like okay back to my pc
i haven't really got there to even need
an ssd
but i am one of those people that i do
not like to delete games
i like to because if i know i'm going to
go back to it within the season or
whatever it's like i want it there i
don't want to keep constantly deleting
and reinstalling
takes too long so i can see where you
guys are coming from that's a bad
problem that's a that's a design flaw
it is so so what is your what's your
take on
on this sort of delay and what it's
going to do to the console
potentially like do you would you rather
wait for a first
party solution or would you would would
you risk getting a third-party solution
oh my god that's a good question it
depends i'm
it depends on the price i think on on
which is you know what the price is for
each of them
and would i take the risk if i knew it
was like
messing up my games or doing something
to that console i probably wouldn't take
the risk i'd have to wait
i guess but then if you're desperate i
mean then at that point maybe i am
deleting games at that point
just to avoid it you know what i mean
and that's the offered award is
desperate right
yeah i gotta get this two weeks ago i
came out here i was like here i finally
folded here's this little card that i
bought for 220 dollars
but but i'm happy since then right i'm
happy like
man i know everybody that got ps5's they
got externals hooked up and there's no
issues man like
because i haven't got one yet did you
see
the holla at your boy with your review
tech you got it up there right now too
yeah yeah
guys you guys are crazy man that must be
that much like just like it's just
random because i swear to god
i should kick him i was in rest mode all
the time i don't know can i ask a
question
is there a need to have like 15 20 games
downloaded
i know i mean it's more of like not
wanting to download them again
like you got to remember people that
have the they have a uh what's your
call they have data caps and stuff like
that you download internet once you
don't want to happen
again that's true i got 19 terabytes
and i use all of it all right so i
download i
i download so you're playing 19
terabytes worth but i don't i don't care
because i downloaded it
really and i just do it because i wanna
boop
it over here get over here
see the thing what blaze said and is
y'all keep missing it
y'all keep missing it the playstation 5
don't have any games
so he can hook up his ssd to it
and play all those wonderful playstation
4 games
that last generation butters listen i
told you guys the hard launch was in
march
it's here march is it's around the
corner
you're gonna start seeing playstation
fives available
and then the real launch is when ssd
come out because that's when they
actually really ready
both of these consoles had a problem
yeah both of them right and
and i'm going to give jason ronald and
his team the
win in this category when it came to
design
when it came to execution when it came
to
getting you your all-in-one package
available
at launch where you can gain without
compromise
now where they faulted that they faulted
in the dev kits
yeah sony dev kits was
on point fantastic their games ran
flawless in the beginning
and a lot of their games also that was
multiplex
was outpacing the biggest stronger dude
they was running rings around and it was
looking like roy jones fighting mike
tyson in there
and literally they held their own
until the development kits matured now
we're starting to see the separation and
certain things but
both of these consoles have their issues
the ssd is a huge problem
i would love to have a uh extra ssd in
my playstation that i do not use it
i'm not lying to you guys when ratchet
and clan comes out i'm going to play it
i'm going to beat it i'm going to move
on
i'm not going to cap and say that it
doesn't bother me
it doesn't affect me but i'm still upset
for a lot of you guys that it is
affecting
that's having this issue that's why i
brought it up just not to just bash on
sony and i like to have fun with them
i can't imagine what it's like for like
uh somebody who's primarily on
playstation who has a lot of games who
plays
all of their third parties for hardness
crazy that's crazy because the thing is
again that's the problem i was having on
xbox all of a sudden you're looking at
you're like i gotta delete this
i got to re-download this i got to move
this to the to the to the external which
you don't have that option right now
on the playstation but for me as
somebody who has their playstation
for their first party stuff even then
it's still
it's it's crazy because again all the
all the like the
the the ghost of tsushima you know
putting on the
little girl exactly exactly
king you got 19 terabytes you know you
know i was just thinking that's crazy
because
gears gears gears one two three four
five all the halos
all the fours you know that's that's a
lot it takes up a lot of space
[Music]
the whole slate blaze definitely
pre-meditated bro cause i'm looking at
my body i got all these bruises i'm like
well i gotta punch this guy back
all right you gotta let that you gotta
let the respect go blaze
i've been on four podcasts this week so
i feel this the other thing i feel like
i'm repeating myself
i've been battling i've been doing this
for everybody wants blaze this week
this blaze is weak they want to blaze
blaze
i say this blaze when you get a series
x you'll be happy i will be i want you
you know why you'll be happy
you'll be happy you can stop playing
with erica on pc
you know why playstation has no games
well actually technically row companies
across play
so but he rather game on pc to
knock the dust off that five um
series x and you it's going to change
your life bro i'm um
you know it you know i'm not capping you
know i'm not capping
listen your controllers don't work
you're not wearing a hat you're right
check this out check this out check this
out
your controllers don't work ssd's not
there
oh god you know uh you have to talk
about the concept did this happen
what what do you got to lose oh my god
okay you know where i got that reference
from if you understand me you understand
what do you have to lose
you guys put out a 200 controller
because your controls
thank you you got the 200 controller
because your controller breaks and you
only got 40 days to play
[Music]
i like now that what they did with
playstation 5 controllers in amazon
they already have a timer down so it's
linked to your amazon account
so aws and um i saw it like
there's a little ticker inside yeah they
should be a new one
they ship you a new one right before
your your old one dies hey who has the
who has the stronger
year like like who do you think has the
most games coming like
your games are next year so you don't
have any games this year we do though
what game ratchet and clank that's it
yeah i mean we got resident evil demo
can you play that demo on next
[Laughter]
what about the return return going to be
fired when it's on sale
it's already six months metacritic right
it's already 61 minutes
metacritic somebody already checked it
out it's already 61. i don't think you
get over 65.
i don't think he'd get over 60 what was
your last metacritic game it was a crash
team racing dusty game right
that game listen i can't believe they
were going to sell that for 70 dollars
destruction all-stars yes they're about
to sell that game for 70 dollars
yeah they backtracked and now it's
twenty dollars on the store
well they it was only gonna be for the
the month right and then maybe either
if you think about it to sell it it was
gonna be 70.
if you think about it like that is so
slimy
the first one is i mean i know that it
out beforehand
even though that it went into
playstation plus
like you know there's some people out
there that bought that for a full
seventy dollars oh yeah
and then a month later it's 20. like
yeah it's correct by the way look at it
i'm not saying he's going to be the next
i was going to ask you
i don't know if guys talked about it
what was your feeling on the state of
play yeah we could talk about it
real quick here then i got then i got a
boogie because it's better listen the
state of play with
their medicine kicking in the state of
play but it doesn't wear off the state
of play was reverend
average it was they showed ev like sony
could have just released some trailers
they didn't need to
unless it was like a deep dive to show
ratchet and clank like all the games
they showed is
stuff like we knew was coming like there
was a couple cool unique games like this
the the saifu game and
do you think that mike do you think that
horizon zero dawn is coming out this
year no oh you think it's good
yeah i think it's coming because me and
cognito were talking i was like man i
was like
i think it's got delayed like i'm really
starting to think it
incognito this stuff is coming they
called cardinals like i don't know man
cognitos i don't know man i think it's
coming out this year how about literally
like an hour after you get off the phone
with him
there's articles being written by almost
anyone you could think of saying that
it's got delayed of 2022.
i don't know i mean it comes
you still figure they got a summer
blockbuster to kind of promote it if it
is going to come this year they got this
summer
all the games has been delayed what oh
my god
but king you don't even have a game
coming out this show okay okay
so so all right no halo check this out
this is where you was yelling at a demo
and we jump out the bushes like gotcha
right
bethesda yeah let's talk this smoke you
want to talk smoke let's talk to smoke i
like bethesda games so
you're going to love them when you buy
it on the x
so the show is coming up in march we all
know this
nice little uh unbeknownst to a lot of
other people
yo in march to announce the acquisition
the highly highly highly sought after
highly paid for
you know seven billion acquisition in in
the microsoft fold
and i believe on that day you're gonna
get starfield and starfield's coming out
this year
yeah and i think it's gonna be an
exclusive too wait starfield's coming
out this year
yeah yeah you want to put knees on that
yeah i i actually look me and king we
could take
a knee each yeah so i'll take your
ankles for this one too listen i hope it
comes out but i i don't think it's
coming i don't want to hear none of that
are we taking your knees or not
all right all right all right you think
starfield is coming out yes this year
this year this year and that's why
before halo
before before halo
i'm not going that far i think halo's
november i think they're just going to
win
november yeah
if that is the case that would be too
major i think halo is october
properly but um anyway like i was saying
the bethesda deal and all the games that
was under the
umbrella seven billion is a reason all
right so
these places are next year
you got paid for demos
[Music]
thank you for demoing a game that's
going to play better on the series x
maybe on the series s that's keeping
pace for the 500
console they could do 4k because right
now they're doing 4k
and they doing 60 frames per second they
do it exactly what you're doing but they
do it
cheaper hello can i get a lot harder
please okay so okay you don't think
what you call is coming this year you
don't think well what is it on horizon
it's covering this year
oh no wow i'm lucky
yeah horizon's not coming this year and
god awards not coming this year
none of those things so they're just
going to say so what's the game
that they had in the background and
stuff that they purchased uh for
uh a minute so that uh what was that
game that they
did you have the death loop the uh no
i mean there's there's rumors that
actually final financial 16 is this year
yeah no i believe so sure i believe
they're going to have to we haven't
really seen enough gay play to think
that that's this year
they had the luffy thing right they have
the the final fantasy 7
yeah that's that's the summer upgrade
listen you guys can win a year bro as
long as we
go you can take the hill as long as we
take the whole city you're good too
listen you know it ain't going to matter
because the breath of the wild to come
out it's folding everybody else
that ain't coming to like 10 years
ain't coming soon and is that that's not
coming to next year you got skyward in
july and then they're gonna
nintendo's gonna ride out they can do it
oh yeah we're getting all kind of
remasters at the end we're going to get
a bundle just like mario
real quick what would you give me a top
selling too they have play
uh i didn't see the whole thing i just
kind of saw the highlights
the trailers because kenneth you didn't
much
was my one of my most anticipated is
kenneth so i watched that trailer
nice beautiful i can't freaking wait for
that game august though i thought it
would be sooner but you know i could
wait
what can we think about the gameplay it
looks awesome i i like
uh it just i like that the gameplay
itself
it kind of matches up zelda it reminds
me kind of reminding me of zelda a
little bit you got the bow and arrow you
got the
abilities that can't seem to come from
her staff talk about the downgrade
the downgrade what downgrade
when we first saw it we saw it only in
cinematic form
and it gave the impressions that this
was what the game would look like why
did cox say oh no
when they actually showed the game
running it looked like playstation 4
game to me
it's statement it's statements like this
that that people think that we're
xbox players this is why
wait a minute didn't they say it's
coming to ps4 as well no yes
it is
why because you can only play so hold on
hold on
little no look kenneth is one of those
games where the art style it's
timeless it's it's not going to be
realistic it's not going to be like
freaking knocking your socks off maybe
it's still going to be beautiful
kind of reminding me of like like a ori
kind of style but like 3d
with zelda you're looking at it 10 years
later it's still going to look great
exactly exactly that's the kind of
will you say it's beautiful then yeah no
and i'm gonna say this right
he's gonna say that x is gonna make it a
next gen game better
it's gonna get used yeah it's gonna look
better it's gonna play better it's gonna
be better
but we know this but i'm not buying it
if it's not a game pass i'm not buying
it
i'm being real with you it'll be it'll
be in game passes
and i'm trying it but i'm not buying it
oh my god
wait a minute
i know you're not really a pc gamer so i
can't really use that part of it but
you're willing to pay sixty dollars for
a nintendo
freaking cart
i said this on twitter too kenna looks
like what zelda
should be looking like and you don't
want to pay money for a four i think ken
is 40.
but you want to spend it on a dusty
skyward sword yeah
that looks the same as ten years ago all
right
check it out sixty dollars check it out
thank you that is 40 bucks right it's
supposed to be i like i heard
i heard i don't know for sure but if
it's true
understand this anytime playstation is
sony though they can sell yourself for
40 bucks
that means there's actually ten dollars
worth of content okay
because they're daily ones the champions
70 games
right they're the ones that's forced the
70 games down you guys throats
and you guys are loving it so when they
tell you it's forty dollars
be on the lookout right are you applying
morale and stuff what are you gonna play
i said i'm implying this is uh something
else but it's not dlc this is the
original game
but okay you said the dusty port right
yes yeah with this dusty part i'm going
to take four controllers
sit down with my kids and we're gonna
play
my kids had to take turns playing that
game by the way if you can find the wii
u anywhere it's still at full price
nintendo their price is the a sale for
nintendo is like five dollars off
it's wild nintendo gets away from that
you can
okay so and i'm not gonna lie
when canada comes out for xbox if it's
not a game pass i'm not gonna buy it
all right that's wild to me so you maybe
you're just not feeling it that much no
no it's not that
the game looks nice i don't i am
spoiled you understand when you go to
the buffet and then you take your kids
to a regular restaurant
what the restriction levels is like when
you got to pay for each meal you're like
hey everybody this is stupid
this is ridiculous i take my kids to the
buffet
they they told me they all looked at me
with tears in their eyes right because
they didn't they never
understood what a buffet was about right
and i didn't notice this
until when we was eating a meal yeah and
they realized they said
this is eating with no restrictions
this is because they said where's the
menu daddy right
i said oh there's no menu i said you see
all that stuff out there
that's you so they look at me and they
look back at me like
you god you
oh god
so my son he don't ever get like when we
go to the restaurant you know you tell
your children
all right you can have the burgers fries
and shake they eat off the kids menu yo
the kid's menu madam
i'm having these ribs i'm having shrimp
i'm having this
i'm having that ma'am may i have some
juice please
getting fruit he's getting ice cream
he's getting cookies
he's whatever they wanted they had
that's game pass
for me right so you're telling me to go
to
arby's or whatever the hell
my food come out fresh date and date no
no no
but listen but you bring up the buffet
example you know the buffet has some
nasty aspects
i don't know where you go to your buffet
but
if you ever had partaking in game pass
that is a premium buffet you know they
got that hard garlic bread on there that
hasn't been
you know what i mean you're gonna skip
that you're gonna go to the ribs
yes no no they're fresh i'm sorry i i
got to go to
you got the hard pizza the hard breath
golden corral
i have to fight for her because they're
giving her some stale food in her buffet
we need to get out of that playstation
now and come over
you see this is what happens see blaze
what happens when y'all eat that
playstation now food
place things like that you think it's
old food
but over here we get fresh dirt
i have no clue how we're talking about
buffet stuff
i'm not gonna play that game unless it's
inside game pass to be honest with you
i'm gonna keep it real with you
it doesn't pique my interest in in the
the part where i have to
spend money yeah my money you have to
earn it
right and it has to be a reason for me
to run out and go get it
so far this year nintendo has earned my
money
twice or three times even the cat tells
you what are you talking about we don't
like buffets
we love buffet she's trying to get on in
on this yeah
yeah yeah like the last thing about the
final fantasy thing
with the state of play did y'all feel
it's a hustle
oh it's definitely talking about the
yuffie thing like why you feed
not your fee yuppy because it's whack
yuppy
yeah it's gonna be free final fantasy
far point a lot of good games right yeah
remedy great games but the thing is if
you get that version
you can't get it yeah okay that's that's
whack to me it's like man like look
everybody who
wanted final fantasy already bought it
or anybody that wanted to play it has
already
bought it and played it for the most
part man get like your ps plus that's a
great perk like yo i'm signing up for ps
plus because i want this ps5 enhancement
but like now it's like damn like i don't
know man i don't like that
i understand it's a morning thing man
but i don't like kind of dirty yeah
yeah the sad part about it is they got
me
i'm not waiting for it to come on if i
mean i
i felt the best game that was inside
that uh
the terrible play
sifu was date death loop
of course
and he told me last time that he hated
praying all of a sudden he liked that
you know it's crazy a lot of people a
lot of people
capping for death loop never played the
dishonored games
i got i got all those games and i paid
for them but um at this point in time
listen
we know it was a pittsburgh show you
guys was yelling out oh god
oh gonna be there they're going to show
decent they don't go to the show that's
the delusional fanboys that want to make
clicky videos to get people thinking
silent hills that's all that wax
why don't they make the same videos
telling how garbage the show was it was
garbage
okay i told you that bro i'm always
going to be honest with you guys
yeah yeah you got other dudes out here
yelling out it was the best show ever
yeah those are the playstation gamers
bro that that so it's like i put on
it's like i put on twitter let microsoft
come out
with an inside xbox and let them end on
someone else's game
and let them end not only on someone
else's game
but an expansion from someone else's
game
and see how quick the internet turns on
but you know when it's playstation
everyone has everyone in their mom has
expectations
everyone does oh i didn't expect nothing
but literally microsoft
will tell you your wig will have nothing
this is going to be for a certain
demographic
this is bull i'm done with this like
yeah well microsoft never has nothing
but oh damn
yeah that's right that's
big shout out to the boss for coming
through feel better bro
better bro and you know we got to keep
going we got to give we got to give a
shout out to luca
we got to give a shout out to luca man
like her her famous quote this week
one of these playstation insiders gonna
be right
they're never right bro no all these
dudes don't own nothing man
nah nothing i have been told more
i've i've been told more playstation
behind the scenes stuff from xbox
people than playstation pizzas yo blaze
always love brother erica you already
know thank you hey claude thank you
doubt my medicine thanks for coming
through
yeah exactly i i promise to that person
that was talking bad about you i'll make
sure i take care of them
no doubt what's up all right back to the
smoke blaze hold on you
you guys got you guys got uh oh he did
it when the boss left see that
yo you guys got uh you guys got faith in
and halo coming up though i'm serious
like do you guys really believe listen
now
they came and they gave a date they
they're working on it they're showing
pictures they haven't showed any more
video which
i want to see at some point fairly easy
pictures though
yeah well i mean they're going to be
comparable man
they're going to be comparable we can't
we can't say these machines aren't
capable of that
so uh of the the picture of halo
infinite
oh our pc pictures i'm i'm
coming out this year i assume the series
x is gonna look similar if not identical
to what those pictures were yeah
i don't know what the xbox original
one's gonna look like
you know hopefully
it ain't coming out if it comes out on
xbox one it's gonna be powered by the
cloud and that's it
yeah there will be knees that we need
let's
let's blaze through these last two
topics let me get these uh super chats
before because we have a bunch and
actually i missed some from before so i
will read those
out
let me see
stitch with the two dollar super chat
i'm here for the smoke get him king
we got all the smoke then we got
everborn with a two dollar super chat i
don't know if he put anything on this
one but thank you again brother
oh no no dance moves is sony's tim cook
steve ballmer yeah have you ever
ever seen steve balber dancing with the
with the sweaty armpits and all that
i love him then we got widowed dragons
tv good to see you on cog hardcore
gamers never let anything stop them get
well my brother no doubt
actually i have another one from 108
that i missed good afternoon iop thank
you brother
uh then we have jean marc lui with the
five dollar super chat
jim ryan don't go on playstation podcast
because all they do is talk about xbox
[Laughter]
then we have ksanti with the five dollar
super chat speak on it king
folks clown and when you say it's a
juggling system go
google and smart [ __ ] people it's real
yeah
it's real it's real then we have uh
eagles fan 76 with the 10
super chat serious topic is the
playstation 5 flawed
i see a complete revision in two more
years and ps5 pro
made with the with some of the missing
features in it with the stable clocks
too the system wasn't built around
cooling in mind
what do you think of that you're right
even though it's quiet it's kind of wild
because that thing is it's huge
yeah you would think it would have that
in mind in that way and it is
quiet yeah and it is quiet erica you're
so right
but it is built around cooling that big
heat sink
makes it that large yeah yeah yeah
and we got smitty smith with the 5 super
chat ps5 ssd storage
sorry i don't see your name on the list
midi is on it today yeah
there you got pixel videos which had
design flaws since ps3 rebuild the drive
yeah yeah i never liked that on the
playstation you would
sometimes you get that and it'll take
forever to rebuild that drive it's
uh hasn't happened to me that much but
it sucks
um jonathan b two dollars super chat
y'all telling me the ps5 needs hooked on
phonics
wow there we have mariano pompa with the
five dollar super chat that quick resume
is chef's kiss
with all those games on the hard drives
yes see yeah that's see
that's something that i cannot wait for
you to try blaze
what's that because it's
it's a utter game changer like right now
i haven't played super lucky tale in
three days
and i just left out of the the where i
was at on the board
when i go back upstairs to play it it's
going to be right where i was at
wow it's out of control it's it's really
out of control that's
cool that is cool bro we got a
rating blade with a five pound super
chat look at the price for the samsung
250 gigabyte ssd
last year was expensive but now look at
look at the xbox solution 220 for one
terabyte
so good luck finding a check checker um
yeah i mean it's good whatever happens
with the playstation hard drive it's
going to be expensive
it just is um so be ready for that um we
got the rubber
now yeah it'll be around the same as the
xboxes same thing
yeah we have the rubber knob with the
five dollar super chat
sony be popping out demos and dlcs
because they know the playstation 5
owners
ain't got no storage space for anything
else jesus christ that was a good one
not true but that was good not true that
was good i like that i like that
then we got raiden blade with the five
pound super jack king weaving in and out
trapped in the corner within this with
no escape then bam he slips out of the
corner
great show like always guys thank you
thank you
thing is built for this all right so
let's move through these last two topics
very quickly um
another announcement that they made this
week was the return of playstation vr
with the next generation
playstation vr coming at some point
during the
uh this generation so um i'm glad
they're doing this guys i'm glad they're
doing this because
i think when it comes to gaming
and the vr space we still just it's not
catching on the way i think
the people who support it in the gaming
space really want to see it and i think
what it would need for that level of
support across the board
is again for a first party to continue
to support it
so i'm glad they're doing this um i
would have liked to have seen it
completely be
a wireless thing but i understand it
needs to use the power of the
playstation um
so i get that but i i do hope that it is
both that you can
disconnect it and connect it when you
when you want the extra power of the
playstation
um and i'm happy they're doing it
because again microsoft doesn't seem
interested obviously nintendo that's not
what they're doing
and you know as an owner of an oculus
quest i think it's
great but i still don't think that it's
pushing that gaming narrative where
you would want it to be right i think vr
is still going to be super huge when it
comes to
like medical applications business
applications that's still continuing to
thrive and move forward
but it feels like it's stagnated a
little bit in the gaming space and i
think we need like i said a first party
to continue to support it
so i'm glad to see that sony's going
that route um i don't know that we see
it
anytime soon because they you know to
sell
this hardware they have to have enough
playstation fives in people's hands
to justify that so i don't know that we
don't see it for another two years but
i'm glad they're doing it so
uh what do you guys think uh i'll go
with you first blaze
yeah uh look so i i i contacted sony to
get the free adapter you just go to the
website you put in the serial number to
your psvr
i own two psvrs and sony had a big mess
up and a big booboo in it nobody really
talked about it but it was ridiculous
they put out a psvr with the with the uh
you know the box
the breakaway box right no hdr support
and then they came out with another one
sash was like god you know so now i had
to go out resell the other one
so it's all good right but this next
psvr is gonna have one cable that's
it one cable and i think they're gonna
utilize that usbc
um and look psvr hasn't really
you know got a hold on everybody because
look let's face it i don't you i love
psvr but i don't use it because it's a
hassle man yeah it's a huge hassle for
all the wires it's a pain in the you
know what dude just to get it going like
with the breakaway box now hdr password
is still cool but there's still so many
wires it looks sloppy i don't like it
it's uncomfortable bro
but everything else about vr when you
put on that helmet man i'm serious it it
just is so
cool it's so immersive and and like i
feel like
you know playstations not only are they
leading the psvr market right because
it's so accessible
no no but i'm saying on pc they're
beating oculus they're beating all those
guys no they definitely
are yeah yeah here they are yeah no they
are
they are in terms of games yes
in terms of games again no they're the
leaders king you know why because
you have a 400 dollar price entry to get
into youtube okay i thought you were
talking about in games purchase like
purchase i would expect it to be a
little bit higher but when you take into
account of the the vibe
the the oculus no because you really if
you think about it like they have what
maybe six million sold on
on psvr right like when you look at
quests when you look at the vive
it that's a drop in like those aren't
selling like that you would think with
the 300 price point for the quest
but it's just like i said like in the
gaming space it just it's not moving the
needle that way
can't you know why you know why because
yeah the the quest is 300 bucks but now
guess what now you need a third now you
need a thousand dollar fifteen hundred
dollar two thousand dollar pc
if you wanna run vr you know right
at the best that you know i mean so this
way you buy a ps4 or a ps5
500 you know you just plug it in it's
gonna work you don't get to worry about
it i had the playstation vr and i just
sold mine
right yeah but for those same issues
that you said
uh with the wires it was actually
horrible
and then i had the first one because i
jumped in
and hdr passed through i had it was hell
literally hell and then i just i just
left it i mean
it was fun when i turned it on it was
very immersive i like i like the shark
game like like when you're going down
to the bottom of the ocean that shark is
really scary it gives you ajitha
um the the resident evil i will tell
everybody today
is the most horrifying thing that you
can do that's the evil seven
yeah right and it looks really good
you know they had uh it was 1080p in
each eye uh
and i think they were the only ones
doing it at that time
um the 1080p in each eye because i think
uh the oculus was a little bit lower
unless you had it hooked up to your pc
the vibe was uh the highest rate one uh
the games were great i actually got
attic to put on a vr headset
uh at uh uh at a pax so we had a good
time with that recorded that i don't
know if we put out that footage
but it was one of my best moments you
know uh because he put on the
playstation
you know the vr and it was really fun um
i like their presence at the shows
what i didn't like uh again was the
wires it wasn't cumbersome
it was a bit um bothersome
it's disappointing that they're going to
have a wire being that you see
oculus 2 is wireless and i hear that
from the
um the vr community but from in light of
what you're saying now the vr community
isn't that strong
and the playstation is probably
dictating pace so
if they have to have it wired to get the
full power out of the playstation 5
to utilize these games in the manner
that they do then i think that is the
viable
option and like sovereign said uh they
need more consoles in the wild for them
to take advantage of
said uh power so two years down the line
probably that does happen
uh and they have a large catalog of
games that can actually reach over
to uh the platform i don't know
um i just think it was too premature i
think they was having a lot of negative
press early so they put this out to
garner a positive press going forward i
i really do think it um you know they're
talking about in the chat how
you know there are there are pc centric
apps that are that are more popular in
vr
than they are on the playstation and
what i mean about playstation's
popularity is
core games core like games coming to to
the vr platform as opposed to
like these sort of experiences obviously
half-life alex is is absolutely amazing
and transformative
not everybody has the hardware to be
able to experience that game the way
it's supposed to
um so yeah i just think
the playstation name even though like
the six million compared to the 130
million playstations that out there is a
drop in the bucket
but i do think that playstation name
matters in terms of the quality of the
games you're getting and at some point
i do think the price point is is
something that needs to be addressed if
that thing comes in at 400 bucks
i don't know that it's gonna move the
needle very much if they can get it to
two
uh no more than three and that's pushing
it
um and it's considerably better than the
old one i think i think we have
something going on
and you know the chat saying vr is
garbage we are just look man
can we just be can we just look you see
me i'm a playstation guy but i buy
i got all xbox [ __ ] like uh excuse my
language but
like stop with the like oh because if it
was on xbox you wouldn't be saying it's
anybody that i know that's tried vr just
tried it that bought it and tried it
doesn't say it's garbage they might say
hey look you know it goes it's not ready
yet yeah it's not ready yet
but nobody ever says it's garbage unless
you know what i mean unless you just
i don't know but if you try you wouldn't
be saying that i promise you
if it was on xbox you'd be loving it too
yeah i wish i could play it i don't have
much to say about this but like i
because my stomach would not allow it i
don't get it
i get motion sickness with like some fps
games and that's without vr so
i i yeah i just it's it's a thing so
um yeah but i mean i wish i could no
i every time i went to like psx or
something some event i stayed away
because i didn't want
i feel like it would ruin my whole day
i'd be sick yeah you know so yeah i
didn't risk it
atlas had a thing for uh
for people that had that problem because
okay
it's uh they have the cinema mode right
when you watch the movies uh
and i had watched a movie inside the
cinema mode and when you put it on
i think playstation does it as well you
sit inside uh
a theater by yourself you know you're in
this it's creepy as hell
and cool you're looking around there's
nobody in there but there's a giant
screen in front of you
so it doesn't move and stuff like that
it just feels like normal
and you're watching the cinema on the
larger screen so for anybody that has
like a small television like a 32 inch
or whatever that would be cool
yeah the screen is like a hundred
like inches it's crazy so this was this
is the sony thing
before the vr headset right you remember
it was like a mixed reality thing
but it was specifically for that it was
like a i don't know like a 150 inch
screen or something like
right on top of your eyes it was bro as
you're looking around you're seeing the
seats and like yeah
it's like you're there yeah yeah as well
they do that like for sporting events
and stuff right yeah
yeah we are in vr i don't want to say
that's pretty neat vr is awesome man it
really is try it man don't matter if you
try it on your pc if you don't want to
play it on play but yeah right
you can go to concerts and stuff like
that everywhere like
uh that's cool like i i forgot what
concert i was looking at
but um it's like little demos that they
had shout out to christopher hart
because
you know i told him that i had it and he
he recommended a whole bunch of uh games
and stuff
and it was just the barrier of putting
all that stuff together
so i think they whittled it down to that
one y and i think that one wire will
help out
but uh for you erica um trying to get
into like a seating situation not a
standing situation right yeah for sure
not standing all over
and try to get into a seating situation
where
you're looking at something that is not
so much
motion heavy but that is more of a
spectator type of mold
and um yeah it's going to be
transformative i'm sure yeah
i want to i do want to try it eventually
i think i will at some point
yeah but don't
awesome and tetris effect because i beat
it on on playstations for good kiss
it'd be cool wow different ball game bro
yeah send me one blaze it is
you want to try it also let me try it
yeah it is something else
addict what are your thoughts on this if
any you guys know
he's like i'm done i'm past
so let's move on to our final topic of
the day
let's tip our 40s
and pour one out for anthem next um
after a week of deliberation i'm
assuming uh ea decided that they were
not gonna move forward with whatever
anthem next was going to be and
they're now refocusing all of their
efforts on making sure that the next
dragon age
and of course the next mass effect are
all they can be
so uh we talked about this last week
what we thought might happen and what we
hoped would happen
um and now we got our answer so tell me
what you guys think lady erica
i'll let you go okay so i played anthem
like the
beta i think it was and um i think my
husband bought the game
and never touched it we just never
touched it um
it it didn't hold my attention it didn't
really do much for me i guess at the
time like it was kind of cool
to hear and there play a little bit but
it just wasn't
anything special i guess i like dragon
age i like mass effect
i'm happy that they're putting the
efforts into that those games
but at the same time like their
resume right now and like what's going
on with these games like andromeda was
kind of a
you know kind of a bust and so i think a
lot of people the consensus anyways is
they're worried about these games
especially dragon age
people are very worried that yeah i
think at first it was like the um
oh what do you call it mike not
microtransaction it was a service based
service that's that's what i'm looking
for yeah service based yeah and now i
think they're
backtracking on that it's not going to
be that which is good
that's very good absolutely they made a
specific announcement regarding that
right because that that information
leaked out
and they had to come out and say like
hey no yes this was our thinking no
we're going back to making you know
quote-unquote core games so
right so if anthem had to like die
for that i mean cool but
it does kind of suck for people who
really were looking forward to anthem
that was one of the biggest
disappointments
in recent like memory for me that i know
of
people it was hyped remember that they
showed the open world like oh
everything's so interactive there's so
many people
and you could talk to anybody and you
get in there and it's like
not like that it wasn't like that um so
i i think it's just the writing was on
the wall it's not really surprising
it doesn't surprise me at all i just
hope that if that
if they are saying it's four dragon ages
four mass effect we're gonna put all our
efforts into that well then i hope it
shows because i like dragon age i hope
it's good
but i'm just kind of like skeptical i
guess ea and
bioware it's just it's kind of
i don't know man i'm just skeptical they
needed they need w's that's for sure and
i think
the mass effect legendary edition that
that's almost a guaranteed w
unless they've they messed that up
somehow almost guaranteed
apparently the miranda booty the thing
was that the way the camera panned it
was during like a very emotional scene
so it's like it just didn't feel like
she's like spilling her guts out her
heart out to you and
it's just focusing on her butt so they
were like nah they're right
he's only one exactly yes
yeah bring back my cheeks
[Laughter]
laura king what are your thoughts on
this okay so um i told you guys it was
gonna die anyway
i told you it was d.o.a when they
announced the game
i told you guys there was no space for
it see this is the difference that i
feel
uh with the um outright is
uh compared to anthem right
uh a lot of you guys was hyped off for
anthem and i just didn't see the space
i see the space where outright is fit
right i see what it can be and what it
should be
because after touching it i see the
distinctness when it comes to the
enemies
and it makes
sense anthem never made sense to me
they never showed you what the enemies
could be
the enemies were always generic that was
my biggest problem with it
it didn't captivate me in that uh in in
a sense
that i had to play this game i wanted to
grind for this game
when i was inside their tower their
tower looked nice
you know but again that's where the bulk
of their energy went
they thought the experience and destiny
was in the tower no we talked about the
tower because that was the main hub
where we go get our bounties and our
stuff we would go check our reward
systems
or whatever that happened there and
that's where
that happens with destiny that's where
they left me at
once i jump off that cliff and i go into
the world the first time is exhilarating
the 45th time it's really not
exhilarating
that i'm finally in the same spot a lot
of things didn't happen how they wanted
it to happen
i just felt that it never captivated the
audience it was gonna die i didn't think
that
ea one had the versatility to pivot when
it got in trouble
two would allocate the absolute funds
needed to maintain this game three
have the developers go in and give you
the absolute
vision that they wanted to give you and
if it wasn't going right
uh change the vision in a manner that
will uh bring in new users
and keep the existing users there so
those three things
they didn't do they did not want to do
and they were not willing to do they did
not commit to the game
fully when you commit to a game fully
that's ubisoft ubisoft will save a dying
game for honor
they they turn for honor into something
that's incredible
rainbow six yeah siege is a big one
yeah yeah siege right now launches with
uh on xbox series x and playstation five
with next generation uh
ray tracing and next generation features
like fast loading
uh quick resume and all these uh you
know smart delivery and all this other
stuff that they were
ready they continued to support they
base they cultivated it and they cared
i don't think ea as an entity cares
about their properties enough
you guys are really harping on uh them
worrying about mass effects i think it's
a cash grab in certain aspects
i don't trust ea with certain ips uh
dragon age they let me down with a lot
of things
so hopefully they do take these other
developers but that's something that
they want us to hear because
they're killing off a franchise so we
want to know what's going to happen with
the developers and what's going to
happen with these resources
and i feel they're just telling us stuff
that we want to hear i don't trust ea
for
anything at all so if i think they're
going to do something right by me
they have to prove it first i don't
trust them they're liars and
it has been uh you know on paper
that they have done this stuff so i'm
sorry i don't trust them i got to see it
first
yeah that's for sure yeah i 100 agree
with that they have to
they they really have a lot of showing
to do so it's going to be interesting to
see
you know obviously this mass effect
thing is just it's
it's everything collected in one and
it's going to be a nice package and
it'll be some nice upgrades but
again it's it seems like a guaranteed
win and
the real you know the real thing is
going to be when they start releasing
these other games
to see if they really listen to the
feedback from the community
um addict what's your thought on this
i just want to say i told you so i want
to say
that from the start i think the last
time one of the times
eric was here is right before anthem
came on well
anthony actually showed up
i know i know what i was saying i was
saying the same stuff i'm saying now
like game ain't gonna do nothing you
know i actually have three videos on my
youtube channel this is let's talk about
anthem why you ain't going to succeed
and people oh you're just hating because
you're a destiny fan
acting like act like because because the
demographic
bias because the demographic that
they're targeting
i guess we don't have no say in anything
like it's
every game that's come out that's been
quote unquote the destiny killer
they're in the bottom of a barrel
somewhere like they done like
like look like you got to build a
foundation
that is different than destiny and these
games continue
to try to be the destiny killer and the
only thing that happens is they kill
themselves
yeah it's relaxed it is
it's it's one of those things like when
you bring
when you try to jump into a market
that's already saturated
and you're coming in with an inferior
product and and just hope in hopes that
just your differentiation from what the
top dog is
is going to be enough to carry you until
you get get the game right
um maybe at the start of the zeitgeist
of something right you can't come in
five years later after some after an
idea is hot and think you're gonna be
able to catch on it just doesn't work
that way and
the part that's crazy solved is they
have the template
they have what works what doesn't work
but for some reason these companies
they it's like oh you know ray's really
really good with destiny let's not do
one
that's not that's not good they don't do
the good stuff yeah well pvp is one of
the things that keep destiny alive
regardless how
pvp is right now let's not do that
it's one of those things like we're just
gonna we're gonna be different for the
sake of being different
even if it's to our detriment um and see
if it sticks
and and it was never going to stick it
was never going to stick in that way i'm
mad just because
i you know i'm the dude that hates this
type of game
and i didn't want to see anthem die
because i think in terms of the lord
that they were building
the gameplay itself the actual the
actual mechanics of playing the game
are fun and and the mechanics are tight
it's just that when you try to
apply that to a looter shooter service
game like king said
there's a lot that goes behind that uh
that you have to be ready for there are
lots of peaks and valleys in developing
a game like that and you have to be
ready for all of that
and it just feels like they didn't wanna
they didn't they didn't pay attention to
uh-huh what it really is let's be real
uh these companies want to put
half and half out they want to feel like
they can just come in there
uh you know throw out some loot like
first off you know
there's more to destiny than just the
loot there's the road to the loot
there's the
you know the the feeling of actually
getting something in destiny
and all these games they lack that
and that that's the part that just blows
my mind it's like look like you know if
you're not going to have pvp
how is it that it took the division a
whole game before they did a raid
yeah how long has division two been out
it's
it's it's that they've had water right
yeah it's the experimentation
trying to be different and see if it
sticks and when you realize it doesn't
then you just look like me too when you
you know a year later you bring out the
same thing that that the
the main game the cataclysms and all
this stuff would be fantastic and shout
out to green mason and
literally just nightfalls that's all it
was
um just night falls what what people
don't get when we play
destiny and when we talk about endgame
stuff because we're doing in-game stuff
today i
i play my rage i do my rage this and i
made sure
that we learn every aspect of it so we
can run
every part of our clan through this
stuff and we learn the stuff it's fun
mechanics that we're learning
and we're growing as a team as team
building skills
it makes you more sociable uh i love
what destiny does to the community
right it brings gamers closer and i
can't wait for it to be
uh cross play on all platforms so i can
play with my playstation brothers over
there
and you know stuff like that i think
that stuff is is needed
um anthem should have tried stuff in
that vein they should have tried
cross play across all boards they should
have tried to remove as many barriers as
possible
to get everybody in as much as possible
to get the
community tighter i didn't see that
effort they said cataclysms and they
said this stuff and
they promised these things and he never
lived up to their promises when you
don't live up to your promises then it
falls on deaf ears at a period of time
and you just start talking and nobody's
listening this is what happened to
anthem
nobody was listening yeah it was
listening to the cries
and it dies that way and if you look at
the effort that was put forth
you know by ea to sort of quote unquote
save it
they allowed 30 people to work on uh
theo theoretically what show us what
you're going to do with anthem basically
you allow 30 people to work on this
and you're setting it up to fail right
let me address slow more real quick
slo-mo says division has two raids in
uh the division two addict uh
and raids are not necessary for a loot
shooter they're not necessary but they
sure do help
like let's just generally like don't
don't look
oh cool they they have two raids you
know what's crazy
the second raid was so whack i didn't
even know it existed
so it is what it is like look i'm not
going to sit here and argue with you
about the division
when ubisoft don't even know what they
want to do with the game i think the
thing about
when you look at destiny as the
archetype of the one they're all trying
to emulate
the thing about destiny is those raids
you know i'm not a destiny guy but i
have to admit those raids
make you work together in a way that
that forces like it forces you
to focus on the task at hand and it it
it amplifies the fun for people who are
really into it
and are really into the mechanics of it
and these rays are very like
mechanically they're very deep
um this is something that again this you
have to really plan this out
for this stuff to work and and and still
find the fun in it like
i can't say anything bad about destiny
rage because
to me when all the other side stuff the
grinding and stuff is done
what every destiny player points to is
that damn raid
you know what's you know what's the
difference between
anthem between the division you know the
differences between them
and destiny vault of glass yeah because
when vault the glass came out
it showed people what in-game content
really is
could be you could yeah and you know you
can you can throw this little persona
slow-mo that no one plays destiny for
the raids which is completely false
well i mean you didn't technically say
that you said that these type of games
don't need a raid
to to be at their their heights no
destiny
yeah i literally wouldn't play destiny
but we we got we gotta we gotta wrap up
let's go okay we gotta wrap it
up so why is it there's content let's
just say it that way like it's it just
needs content no i don't want content i
want rays
let's finish out with blaze they they
ruined two games at the same time
they had bioware's b team working on
andromeda
they so they screwed up mass effect
series for people
and then they screwed up bioware's
reputation and then ruined anthem like
anthem was never
you could clearly see what anthem was
trying to be but they just
they just couldn't get the game was
beautiful right i was like wow you're
flying around like you said but then it
gets old it's like all right what are we
really doing there's no exactly there's
no foundation here like what what is the
what is the point of doing this right
and like attic said the vault of glass
is just
memorable man that like you're never
going to forget the first time you went
through the vaulted glasses
you'll never forget it bro never you
know i never forget when i got the
fatebringer or the vex smith the class
and i'm like screaming i'm like yo what
come yeah man like but i i will say this
man you'll be
not to get off topic a little bit but
ubisoft gets a lot of flack bro but
ubisoft
you know hey man they try man you know
every every time a game that i that i'm
passionate about dies i'm like why
didn't ubisoft make that and i beat the
division two
everything i beat everything in the
division too i loved it i played the
hell out of it it's great but i think
that
the thing is with destiny 2 is destiny
you're shooting aliens so
we don't know what these people are
you're shooting these you know we don't
know where they are
division but you're shooting a division
guy that looks like blaze with a hood
yeah a thousand times it don't make
sense
yeah that's so cute slow-mo says but
that is destiny not every loose shirt
needs that uh it's funny because destiny
fans claim
every loot shooter wants to be destiny
but when it doesn't do
that kind of content well guess what
slow-mo those other games
they're not successful didn't they say
like only
10 or 15 percent even completed the raid
the raid and they still play and they
still play destiny every day but people
don't even touch the rate because they
can't get enough people involved
yeah and i think and i think the raid
stuff when it comes to the
if you really love that teamwork aspect
of it but i think that like
so shady in the chat said i have a
thousand hours in destiny not a hundred
never done a raid i but again i think
the
the loop is is also addictive to a
certain type of player right like if i
had the time to invest in destiny
i would be lost in that loop shady i
would tell you this right and i will
tell
everybody i tell everybody to add me on
xbox
add me on xbox all right it's called
king david otw add me on xbox
i'm on destiny all day every day um
if you need one of those grandmaster
nightfalls we can work you through it
uh we will take one person through the
raid so you can see
what the content is shady
it will open up a whole different aspect
of your destiny
playing a raid with us uh it's a
different level it's different things
it's certain guns that you get out of
the raid that you can't get any place
else and those guns are actually
necessary to do other aspects of the
game
it makes the game easier so i mean not
to beat the
the dead horse anthem is dead we knew it
was yeah it was just a matter of time it
came in all life support
and they decided to pull a plug um i
honestly thought that they would have
been smart enough
to double down make anthem two
make it better and push forward they
didn't do it
um they didn't see the viability in it
and only only uh ea knows the metrics
that they do have
yeah and they only they know the cost
and the loss that they are suffering so
with that note that's dead we're done
yeah and
uh uh yeah r.i.p anthem irp anthem
um we never knew you unfortunately i
never knew you
never knew you yeah unfortunately um
you had to die for hopefully hopefully
for other things to be better so but we
will see that remains to be seen so
don't trust them
ah big shout out to everyone who rocked
with us today three plus hours again
when we said we weren't gonna do it
he lied like he ate of course everybody
kills all their franchises
live bastards that we are so um
ryan right now that's crazy full circle
lion ryan exactly
so big shout out to our guest lord 4k
blaze 4k and of course lady um erica for
the win
lady erica where can we find you oh uh
my name i think is on the thing erica
it's for the win
that's my name everywhere so you want to
find me on twitch i'm there
youtube twitter even tick tock i made a
tick tock recently you want to see
something
oh really i'm kind of doing the thing i
just put her
i just put her twitter in the chat yeah
you can find all my stuff through there
i always
post like when i'm live and all that
stuff but thank you guys so much for
having me
i wanted to give you guys some freaking
credit right now because the glow up
with this podcast man
the first time i think i was on you guys
maybe had a hundred people maybe in the
chat
yeah family members just family members
that's it
sock accounts nah but like the glow up
you guys man you run a tight ship
you guys got it going on here and i just
want to give you guys respect like
you're doing a great thing
and ever since i've been a guest like
with you guys it started to open my mind
of like
these are what podcasts can be because
you know i was kind of in this bubble of
like
these smaller podcasts you know kind of
like all over the place yelling over
each other and things like that and i
came on here and i realized like man you
guys if this could really be
you know on a professional level and
like like at this level and you guys got
it so i just wanted to tell you guys
that
keep it going and uh and everybody hit
the like button
you guys deserve it and uh that's it
thanks for having me
thank you so much like i tell you like i
all praise be the cog on that one
because cog is the one that gives
organization to this otherwise
it is literally the animals running the
zoo like it really is
you guys are great you guys are great
you deserve it thank you guys
lord blaze where you gonna be at man
yeah man
you can follow me on blaze 4k youtube
twitter um
erica what you just said is what i've
been preaching to addicts
to con you know to king to all look
these guys have a structured
podcast bro there's no very incognito
told me a thousand times
when i'm on discord with cogniton attic
you know i'm swearing i'm incognito like
a thousand
my first times at gill blaze no swearing
all right you know what i mean i know
you do your thing do you think we just
don't swear i'm like all right and
before i get off yo blaze i'll see you
tomorrow yo remember no swearing
and it's like bro he's dead serious
about this stuff
and when you come on here you feel you
just feel like
your time you're being respected um yeah
valued
you feel valued and not only that the
chat
bro it's super chat super chat the
everybody just feels valued it feels
like a family
and honestly i i just like doing it i i
just like being around you guys solve
your
you're a great guy bro thank you bro you
know
you already know what it is king alright
you know what it is
anybody who comes on this podcast knows
that after you come you know you know
how
like with me with friends like when when
you come to my house the first time
i serve you one time when you come to my
house if you come into my house after
that with any sort of
regularity the fridge is right there
yeah the fridge is right your home
your home the fridge is right there and
and that's
that's the way i consider you guys like
you know people have been on our podcast
multiple times and come on that's family
that's family you guys come in and you
know there's
you we don't necessarily need the pomp
and circumstance because we just jump
right into our our flow
and the flow is just natural um so and
that's thanks to you guys as well
because you guys come in
and you could tell you guys feel
comfortable around us and talking to us
so
um fantastic having you we really
appreciate it obviously when cog is not
here
things could go left well i think we did
okay
yeah good job the wizard behind
the curtain lord addict thank you sir
where you been
where are you going what are you doing
back to bed yeah
[Laughter]
no doubt thank you lord adam much
appreciate it lord king where can the
fine people find you talk about the
king of statues and everything you're
doing well first of all i want to thank
uh
erica for the win for coming through uh
tick-tock erica
i gotta try doing the thing you know i
gotta check it out
i do appreciate it i love the cat the
cat walked through was like yeah
i love buffing yeah she came at the
right time with her you know
buffet talk i do appreciate it i do
appreciate you coming through i do
appreciate you giving your time
and like i said before your voice is
the loudest voice because that's the
voice that all these people want to hear
they want to hear the female demographic
that
plays multiple consoles that is agnostic
that is a gamer true gamer you know and
your name says it all erica for the win
you know if you want to pick
you want to win you better pick erica i
appreciate that
means a lot thank you yo i do appreciate
it and my man
blaze yo sure my man does not run from
any smoke anytime at all like
to come on this week when it was like l
after l
after l after l after l and still come
in and spar
and and and hold his own 100 percent
um i don't i don't give him kid gloves
he knows i i give him
you know blaze you you know you got to
come to the to that
whatever e3 microsoft does this year you
got to be in that reaction show you know
that right
yeah he'll be there um that's that's
that's my dude much respect like i said
if
i get my hands on a series x out of my
matrix
uh to to get that to you i'm not playing
bro okay
you know you know i'm my captain i get
my hands on it uh
i slide it your way um thank you guys
for coming out
uh okay so you guys are following me uh
you'll notice that uh kos has been a
little bit off the radar it's been off
the radar because
you've been seeing me doing live
unboxings with uh hulkbuster
uh you know six thousand dollars there
and a couple of thousands over here
and uh this last one i just did
which was green goblin xm green goblin
i'm changing everything around doing the
red room is being done
the the black and purple room is being
done and
this room is being done as well because
i'm doing the modifications the
modifications is upstairs
so i'm doing that so from going from
live unboxing
to take the hot tub out of the purple
room put shelves in there
it's nice so from going from live
unboxings
from uh on dcx y'all can check them out
over there
uh kos is coming because i have a
different format
where it's going to be like a sit down
and talk with the statue type of thing
it's going to be very nice i'm doing
that and also
boxing is kicking back up so combat talk
with the king will be showing back
up uh we're starting to get fights that
we want to see
you catch me on twitter uh that is king
david otw
same name on xbox live
on my playstation live um my playstation
uh account which i still haven't got
into
it it's still frozen jesus you know what
yeah i send a link and i say send me the
link so i can reset my password i really
don't care because i haven't been
playing it
right so it's it's it's a thing like if
you're not
accessing it it doesn't matter but it's
xbox 360 level one
and when it does matter that's your name
on psn
yeah 360 level 1. i got a little monkey
avatar because i love ape escape
i love it so if you've seen me
change that name come on i'm never
that's why they're blocking them
i'm never going to change it because i
love it um and they allow me to do it
and
think about it you imagine him calling
sony like yeah what's your username and
password uh
xbox 360 level oh yeah yeah he just gets
a diatom
yeah but think about it this way i could
not put xbox 360 level because somebody
else had it oh
boy right so that means i didn't think
about that all by myself
so somebody out there has that name by
themselves and i had to put an old one
behind it because i was gonna keep that
name
but um i do appreciate everybody that
did come out everybody that did rock
with us
i do appreciate all your time i do
appreciate all your super chats
and i do appreciate when we got knocked
off that came right back
fantastic again i'm going to tell you
guys please
go to everbornsaga.com
uh go purchase some merch go support uh
go to his kickstarter
hit us kickstarter up uh let's get this
game
out and into the wild and let's make him
uh
a game pass uh developer let's let's
let's let's let microsoft or sony i
don't even care if he gets it to
playstation now
i will buy playstation now if his game
gets launched at the playstation now i
will support him
anywhere i can i don't care if he's in
epic store i will support him there
i will support him in steam wherever the
hell his game is launched that i'm going
to support him
uh but please guys let's get out there
because this
guy is a single father uh taking care of
his kid
uh he's worked up the bootstraps watch
the old show
last week's show to see his story to see
his journey
and he's everybody you know he's all of
us he's each and every last one of us
he's a struggling artist and he's our
comrade let's help him out let's see
what we can do for this guy let's get it
done
wow no doubt well said king well said uh
everborn is a
awesome guest awesome story man again he
comes from where we come from
got a special place in my heart for that
dude's story and his journey so i'm
happy to support and you guys should as
well um
for me you know where i'm going i'm
going to work unfortunately
this is this is what i do this is what i
do so you can catch me um
lordsof ilp on twitter retweeting
everything under the sun
and of course of bx sovereign on psn and
xbox live
uh big shout out to everybody who rocked
with us the entire way
uh you guys are amazing in the chat uh
fighting amongst each other let's keep
it civil everyone
um of course big shout out to our two
guests like i said you guys the family
come back here anytime you know door's
always open door is
always open um and you guys remember to
check out the last
word with ebontus and lord cognito this
past week i don't think katino was on
but they had thai guy travis on
and we're talking about the recent delay
in the this
upcoming season for destiny 2 but um i
think
bungie and destiny are in a fantastic
place man they're bulking up for some
big things
down the down the road so it looks uh
microsoft
but it's fanta you know because i care
because they might actually make a game
i care about now again
that's why i care i care about the new
ip not destiny
wow this is ridiculous um beyond that
like i said oh
check out lords of gaming.net um our
fantastic writers over there
for the latest in gaming news and
actually and pop culture like
there we have such a big variety of
articles
and new writers coming onto the site
fantastic stuff these guys are doing
they work
so damn hard so check out
lordsofgaming.net for all of your news
and like i said at the the top of the uh
at the top of the podcast
give a big shout out love good thoughts
good vibes
to lord dizzy um keep them in your
thoughts keep them in your prayers
all right i want to say one thing about
gaming.net
uh logicgamer.net has got
writers jobs in the industry right so
if if you're looking to take this
serious
and you're looking to get your foot in
the door make sure that you uh
sign up for loads of gaming.net to be a
writer to
to to be some uh form of journalist to
get your
your written work out there to you know
get your paces to
to get through it and i urge you to go
to look at lordsagama.net
every time i go to the website it puts a
terror in my eye because
we're challenging ign and these big
sites we
want it to be egm that's electronic
gaming that website's
thank you sir yeah so yeah absolutely
fantastic job over there so once again
thank you everyone for joining us enjoy
the rest of your sunday and we are
out watch this outro
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
so
[Music]
you